welcome to another episode of the
stronger by science podcast Greg starts
off today's episode with some very
impressive feats of strength and then we
have a huge research roundup segment in
this segment we talked about some recent
research comparing different types of
whey protein Greg takes a deep dive into
the research on phototherapy
we talked about glycogen depletion and
replenishment the use of coffee as a
pre-workout supplement some recent
research on lower back pain and more to
finish off the episode we have an
interview with Ben [ __ ] and we talk
first about power building which is
basically how to train for power lifting
and body building simultaneously and we
also talked to Ben about the subject of
his PhD which is the history of physical
culture if you'd like to support the
podcast by subscribing to our monthly
research review called mass this is a
reminder that the mass Black Friday sale
is currently happening right now you can
get 30% off of all subscriptions with a
large percentage of our profits going to
this year's charity of choice which is
the American Foundation for Suicide
Prevention that sale is happening right
now and it ends December 2nd as always
thanks for listening and enjoy the show
welcome back to another episode of the
stronger by science podcast today I'm
joined by a special temporary guest host
named Greg knuckles thanks for inviting
me thank you for accepting my invitation
I tell you what Greg we've got a lot to
get to today so I'm gonna suggest that
we dive right into feats of strength yes
sir so I have four things picked out for
today
I'm gonna lead with the one that
probably everyone is expecting and that
is this feats of strength segment I feel
like we should just rename it the Julius
Maddox update segment because I feel
like that's what we do a lot but he
recently competed again in the lead up
to this meet he benched 700 for a triple
paused so everyone was expecting big
things coming in he ended up breaking
his own all-time world record he
bench-pressed 744 pounds which is three
hundred thirty seven and a half kilos
that beat his old world record by two
kilos was 335 and a half or 739 and it
was good to see this because as we
talked about with the prior record the
press was smooth looked like one of the
spotters hit the bar so after he got the
rack command he just kind of like
dropped to the bar on his chest it was
not a good looking scene I don't think
any of that was his fault but you know
this new world record is absolutely
faultless it is a picture-perfect bench
press it's also worth noting he got it
on his second attempt the word I heard
is that he was looking for 350 kilos or
771 on his third but he felt some PEC
tightness after a second so he just
decided to you know shut it down after
breaking his own world record rather
than risk injury so I didn't see this
lift based on how it looked
the 770 does that look like it's like on
the table I mean it's hard to tell
he's one of those types of guys who
either gets it smoothly or mrs. right
comparing the 744 he did to the third
rep of his 704 a triple the 744 looked
easier than that third rep so I do still
think he had something left in the tank
but just watching his lifts it's hard to
tell whether he has ten pounds in the
tank or 40 so I don't know I I'd
probably give it a coin flip yeah I mean
but we know what it's like you're you
got 700 on the bar you're hitting that
third rep it'll sneak up on you you know
in theory sure yeah
so that happened it's awesome he is
pushing bench press into frontiers that
no one else has still making reasonably
consistent progress so you know is he
going to break 800 before anyone else
even breaks 750 who knows I wouldn't be
shocked
so moving on Kahler woolum recently tied
the deadlift world record in the hundred
ten kilo class or 242 pounds
he pulled for 32 and a half kilos or 953
pounds that ties Christoph we're bickie
he had previously pulled that same
amount but he did it in a deadlift only
meat whereas Caylor woolum did it at the
end of a three lift meat which you know
tends to take something out of people so
ties the world record but in my book is
slightly more impressive there was a bit
of controversy about this lift so it
looks like kind of like double clutched
to the start a little bit and so in the
rulebook if the plates break off the
ground that is your attempt and it's
just a question of whether you lock it
out or not it kind of looks like the
plates may have barely broken off the
ground then touch the ground again and
then broke the ground again to lock out
so kind of like as he was tensioning
himself he maybe put a little bit too
much mustard into it my take on that
I don't give a [ __ ] double-clutching the
start of a deadlift it doesn't make the
lifts easier folks so I mean personally
I like strength sports because I like
seeing strong people do strong things
and so like that's a rule we're like
whatever it's a rule I don't care about
the rules or like this one specifically
because this isn't it doesn't make the
lifts easier you know it's not like he
hitched it even though I think Hitchings
dumb as well but that that's another
conversation for another day but it's
not even like he did something that made
made it easier like he pulled it to my
eye it actually looked like a cleaner
lift and we're bicky's I didn't think
we're bicky's was locked out but that's
also more controversy this is a very
controversial deadlift record all around
but anyway he pulled it he locked it out
and I personally am impressed that's
gonna be if you ever run for political
office the attack ad is gonna be Gregg
knuckles saying I don't care about the
rules that's going right into the the
audio Bank oh man
that's probably true okay um so moving
on once more
Jackson Powell if you haven't heard that
name there's a good reason for it
he is 17 years old and I don't know if
he's ever competed I think he has but
you know not like prolifically so if you
don't know the name learn the name
posted a training lift of himself
squatting 800 pounds which is three
hundred and sixty three kilos high bar
two which was interesting so fun fact
not that many seventeen-year-old squat
eight hundred so the world record for
any seventeen-year-old is Joseph Pina he
squatted three thirty six and a half or
eight hundred eight hundred and six
pounds when he was seventeen so this is
the second heaviest squat by a
seventeen-year-old ever caught on video
as far as I'm aware
but the noteworthy thing about it is in
addition to Jackson Powell and Joseph
Pina I think only one other
seventeen-year-old has ever squatted
over 700 and so you know they're just
kind of over there an outlier freak
territory but yeah strong kid and I
strongly assume he is going to keep
getting stronger so very impressive
stuff from him and then finally I think
this is our first feat of strength that
is actually a failed lift but it is
impressive enough to me that I think
it's worth including Yvonne Makarov who
is a strong man from somewhere in
Eastern Europe posted a video of a very
close miss in a training lift dead
lifting 501 kilos or 1104 pounds
Eddie Hall famously has the strongman
deadlift record at 500 kilos Makarov
seems to be making a pretty hard run at
that record and it's so you should go
find the video because it's interesting
he he gets it above his knee pretty fast
and pretty smooth and then he like I
don't know just fails very quickly and
it was interesting to see because like
he competes in strong man and strong men
can ramp they can hitch like those are
things that are perfectly allowed and
strong man and so generally if you see a
strong man get a lift above their knees
they're gonna lock it out because they
just have more tools in their arsenal to
be able to do so he posted in the
Instagram caption like for this video
that he tightened his suit too much so
he couldn't get a good breath so it's
possible that he like failed very
suddenly because he started blacking out
like he sat the bar down very quickly
and like instantly went to a knee so you
know maybe he had the strength for it
but was just blacking out not totally
sure
but more recently he posted via a video
of himself doing block polls from
Bologna height with 540 kilos which is
eleven hundred and ninety pounds like
office 1200 pounds so I mean it seems
like he has a lockout strength to
lockout a mere 1100 so you know he
didn't get the lift but it was a damn
close attempt and Eddy Hall's
record doesn't look as safe as I thought
it was and certainly is as safe as Eddy
seemed to think it was but yeah we we
very well may be seen the next 500 kilo
deadlift her soon which is exciting
definitely I'm still just I can't get
over the fact that Julius Maddux appears
to be in his like 14th consecutive year
of noob gains yeah it's just linear
progress on top of progress dude it it's
wild he was kind of stalled there for
like two years or so kind of
consistently hitting numbers between
about 650 and 700 and just the last two
years it seems like his training has
really started clicking I don't know
when he linked up with with Josh Bryant
I know that's his current coach you know
maybe he had like stalled and then
that's when he went and started getting
coaching by Josh and that's you know
what really kicked things into overdrive
but man the the last two years from him
have been crazy he's he has talked about
being the first person to bench 800 and
I'll tell you what man
I believe it I have no reason to
disbelieve it with recent history okay
so let's move on to the next segment
we've gotten a lot of good feedback in
the past when we do research round up
segments so it's kind of you know we do
some more in-depth research reviews
where we look at one paper and get
really granular with a detail but the
research roundup segments a little
different because we
do kind of like a highlight reel you
know we talk it enough about the study
to really get some good conclusions then
we move on to the next one so we've got
a nice research roundup and one of the
reasons we wanted to do it is because
many listeners probably know Greg and I
publish a monthly research review called
mass with our good friends dr. Mike zort
Oh dr. Eric Helms Dicey's or doe I think
he did dr. Mike Soros and dr. Eric Helms
and one of the hardest parts of mass
every month is Greg goes through and
does a journal sweep and we get all
these potential articles to review and
trying to narrow it down to like two or
three to choose that month is so
difficult so we end up with this huge
list of studies that were interested in
but don't have the bandwidth to do a
full write-up of and so a lot of the
studies we're going to talk about here
are basically studies that nearly made
their way into mass but didn't you look
like you're about to say something oh I
was going to say that might be your
experience like so in terms of the total
amount of nutrition versus training
studies that get published I think
there's a somewhat comparable amount at
least in terms of like sports nutrition
stuff obviously there's a ton of like
clinical nutrition research that gets
published as well but my experience is
very much the opposite there's like
every month there's probably another I
would say solid four or five studies
where it's like man I wish I wish
Shrek's her Helm's could have tackled
that one I feel like between me and Mike
we've review five studies every month
and I think like more often than not
there's four that are really good and
then it's just kind of like who gets the
fifth and how can we try to make it
sound like it's cool yeah my experience
is very different I feel like I don't
want to speak for Helm's but with all
the stuff coming out in the sport
nutrition world it's just such a moving
target there are so many different
topics to to invest
in like man this month we talked about
you know sucralose and its effects on
the gut microbiome and like yeah I tried
to find all the Studies on the human gut
microbiome and it's basically nothing
you know there's still these new rocks
that were kind of turning over every
single month but in any case III think
the I think the thing with training
studies is like there are a lot of
topics being investigated that sound
cool but it's kind of one of those
things I mean you you read our stuff so
you know this where it's like the topic
sounds cool but then we actually get
into the full text and we look at the
design and we're like god dammit why did
you do that right yeah it's like so
close and then you find something you're
like I can't do anything with this yeah
so I mean shameless pitch that's one of
the value-adds of mass like all of us
have done research and have formal
training in research design so like we
we see a lot of things we see a lot of
popular studies get shared around and
then when we pull them up to look at
them it's like ooh there's some pretty
major design issues in this study that
we haven't seen literally anyone talk
about I mean I think part of that is we
know a fair amount about research design
I think a larger part of that is like
most of the people who talk about
research on social media don't bother to
ever read the full text in the first
place but yeah that's that's one of the
things we do for you like not just talk
about what the research found but
whether it was adequately designed to
draw the conclusions that it is
attempting to draw definitely so I'm
gonna dive right in I've got a study
picked out here it's by Castro at all
and it is it's called comparative
meta-analysis of the effective
concentrated hydrolyzed and isolated
whey protein supplementation on body
composition of physical activity
practitioners so basically what they're
looking at it's a meta-analysis looking
at different forms of whey protein
looking at how it affects body
composition in people that are
undergoing physical activity so a
meta-analysis we talked about them
before basically you're just searching
the literature
systematically and trying to combine the
results of several studies that are
similar in terms of their design and
their research question so you can
summarize the overall findings in that
body of literature so the reason I
wanted to talk about this study like you
mentioned it's one of those things where
I look through the abstract and some of
the findings I was like wow that's
really surprising if not
counterintuitive and then digging
through the results it makes a lot more
sense when you get into the full text
and you say oh okay
I see what's going on and with a
meta-analysis that's really not
meta-analysis assuming you do it
reasonably correctly is like on the
researchers side it's like what do you
want me to do I just told you I was
gonna find this stuff and crunch the
numbers so it's no fault of the the
authors for sure but let me get to the
point here so their search yielded eight
studies with a total of 246 subjects
between them and the average duration of
these protein interventions was sixty
four point five days now the interesting
findings related to two fatness and what
they found was that over all the way
protein supplementation interventions
did yield a significant loss of fatness
where things got a little bit
interesting was when they looked at some
of these subgroup analyses so this is
common and meta-analysis where you might
say okay so we found sixty studies and
we found this effect but you know maybe
25 of them of them were in women and the
rest were in men did we maybe see
different results in the you know a
female subgroup versus the male subgroup
or something like that so it when
there's a lot of studies it makes a lot
of sense when there are fewer studies
it's a fairly limited approach you got
to be a little bit careful with with how
how aggressively you interpret the
finding of that type of a subgroup
analysis so what they did was they
looked at some subgroups and they looked
at weigh concentrate versus whey isolate
and they found the
the reduction of fat mass was found in
the way concentrate studies but not in
the way isolate studies which when you
compare away concentrate and isolate
it's a little bit counterintuitive you
wouldn't you wouldn't expect that to be
the case and so when you look a little
bit closer at the results of that
comparison what you found was the like I
said the way isolate did not
significantly reduce fat mass but the
the way concentrate did but the non
significant effect of whey isolate was
actually bigger than the statistically
significant effect of whey concentrate
so what really happened there was we
basically had in the the whey
concentrate group very few studies it
actually only had I think I only had
three studies in it but two of them
reported very narrow confidence
intervals and so what that does in a
meta-analysis is basically inflates the
it I should put it the other way it
reduces the p-value to a relatively
extreme amount when you have extremely
narrow confidence intervals for a
particular study it contributes it pulls
a little bit more weight of the analysis
so to speak and so basically what
happened was when we looked at the
overall mean change in fat mass for
concentrate or isolate the effects were
basically the same and in fact the the
mean change for a whey isolate was
bigger than than it was for concentrate
but because the way concentrate had
these very narrow standard deviations
for two of those three studies it was
statistically significant and the other
was not but when you look at that it's
really important with a meta-analysis
not just to look at the p-values but you
got to look at the actual size of the
effect and so it's one of those weird
things where you know if I told you two
different groups did a benchpress
intervention one group increased their
bench by thirty pounds the other one
increased their bench by twenty five but
the twenty five was significant and the
thirty wasn't there's no way you would
look at that intuitively and say oh give
me the one that increases it by twenty
five
yeah the other group got better buy more
it was just because there was a little
more variability it wasn't it didn't
cross that magical threshold of being
statistically significant yeah I mean so
depending on like the difference and
variability it could influence what you
were doing so you know let's just say
theoretically it's 30 30 pounds plus or
minus 30 pounds and 25 pounds plus or
minus 5 pounds if you're say a strength
coach for a high school football team
and you really want to make sure that
the vast majority of your athletes
improve over summer workouts you very
well may go with the 25 plus or minus 5
versus 30 plus or minus 30 so you know
and I guess that kind of depends on
philosophy like if you really just want
to grow a handful of freaks and you
don't really care if a fair amount of
other people crash and burn you go with
the 30 plus or minus 30 so in Scituate
and that's a purely theoretical
situation I don't know if I've ever seen
a paper that actually had results like
that but theoretically if there's huge
differences in variants that could
actually be meaningful if like the
consistency of the effect does matter
quite a bit more to you than the actual
magnitude of it but in virtually every
situation like like this one where you
do see something like that where the
thing that has the larger effect size
isn't significant but the other thing is
it's generally like not actually that
meaningful of a difference in variance
it was just like you know slight
differences and one is a p-value of 0.04
and the other one's 0.06
and because people just [ __ ] turn
their brains off when they read
statistics they're like oh yep one of
the matters and the other doesn't
yeah and I completely agree with you but
I would also add a layer to that when
you're talking about meta-analysis you
also have to keep in mind that some of
the things contributing to that
variability might just be design
differences population differences or
the way the outcome was measured
and so in some cases you might find it's
not that the effect was more significant
or more consistent in this subgroup it's
that they used a more consistent
measurement tool yeah or they sampled a
population that happens to be more
consistent than the other or if it's a
random effects model you just have
simply more studies in there like that's
gonna increase power and decrease the
the variance of your pooled effect
estimate yeah so so meta analyses have
become the thing that really get me
excited these days I don't know why I
just seem to be gravitated toward them
because I think I think they lend
themselves to misinterpretation pretty
frequently but anyway what I was getting
at with this particular study it was one
of those things where that finding jumps
out at you and then you look at the
full-text you're like okay these were a
bate they were basically the same like
the magnitude of change was pretty much
the same one of them just had slightly
tighter standard deviations but at the
end of the day whey concentrate whey
isolate it's the same thing basically so
so that was one of those things where
you look into it a little deeper and you
go oh never mind
same kind of thing they found with their
subgroup analysis that when the whey
protein I'm sorry when the protein
content of the supplement was between 51
percent and 80 percent by weight they
found a significant effect but not when
it was over 80 percent by weight and
that is pretty counterintuitive because
you'd think if the whole purpose was to
look into this protein supplementation
more protein would be better if not as
good you know than a lower percentage
protein product and so that was another
one that caught my eye I think what was
happening there sometimes what you'll
see is you can get a little bit of
artifact in these meta analyses so if a
subgroup only has maybe two or three
studies in it every now and then they
just happen to be the two or three
studies that were most or least
impressive in terms of the magnitude of
effect it's kind of just a game of
chance at that point and so with with
that it's you know if you told me that
you had 16 studies in each subgroup and
the lower percentage protein
products outperform the higher
percentage one then I'd say you got
something but when we're talking about
looking at such a small number of
studies and trying to find the mean of
these very small groups one study that's
particularly impressive with its
refining with with its findings or
particularly modest in terms of the
effect size that can completely throw
your average and all of a sudden that
subgroup analysis is a little bit skewed
again no faults and the researchers
that's the way it goes sometimes but
it's like one of those things when
you're talking about literally having
two or three studies in a subgroup it's
like pull a coin out of your pocket and
flip it four times if you get heads
three of those four times you're not
gonna say whoa this is a special coin
right like yeah when you have really
small samples or a really small number
of studies every now and then we see
little tiny patterns emerge that are not
patterns they're just artifacts you know
so another thing that they found was
they found that the effect on fat mass
was significant for people who were
trained rather than sedentary leading
into the study so like fairly active
people rather than sedentary people at
the time of enrollment but again it was
one of those things where one group the
change was significant the other group
it was not but the mean difference in
terms of fat mass for one group it was a
loss of 0.92 kilos for the other group
is a loss of 0.95 that is the same
change right like yeah if we're gonna
get down to a couple of tenths of a kilo
as being the real distinguishing factor
between working and not working yeah
those were the same number the sedentary
subgroup only had two studies in it
there was no chance that was going to be
significant dude the more the more you
tell me about this meta-analysis the
more I feel like this should be like the
poster child study for everyone who
doesn't like frequentist statistics yeah
there's a little bit of that going on
you know it's tough so with these
subgroup analyses I think a lot of
people
we'll do them because they're like
listen this will be cool we'll be able
to you know explore some patterns in
there and I frankly I'm kind of a kind
of guilty of this myself I mean I did a
meta with very few studies and did some
subgroup analyses but in the paper
I begged people not to over-interpret
them and I said by the way I did a
formal moderator test for all of these
none of them were significant these are
purely for forming hypotheses for future
studies do not over like I must have had
probably six disclaimers begging people
please don't misinterpret it's not that
you can't do it you just want to make
sure that you interpret it extremely
cautiously and have several disclaimer
saying this is purely so that whoever's
gonna run their next whey isolate study
hey maybe you look at whether they were
sedentary or trained or you know it's to
form hypotheses to to help researchers
move this body of literature forward so
yeah there are some dangers with meta
analyses for sure but but they're also a
really powerful tool so it there's a
little bit of a lot of people have
love-hate relationships with meta
analyses because they can be so
informative but they can also be
misinterpreted pretty egregiously
sometimes now when it comes to fat free
mass there was no effect in any of the
scenarios that they investigated and
that shouldn't be super surprising when
it comes to the protein literature I
think it's I think we've got enough of
an understanding about what protein does
and what it doesn't that it's safe to
say that the effects of protein
supplementation particularly for for fat
free mass or lean mass you're going to
be entirely contextual so you need to
make sure that this intervention is
changing total protein intake from less
optimal to meaningly more optimal in
terms of their overall protein intake
and the effect of that protein
supplementation is going to depend on
their training status it's gonna depend
on their training stimulus their overall
diet there are so many factors that come
into play so it's one of those things
when
read a study and says oh way protein
didn't help with with lean mass they
didn't just debunk whey protein you just
saw a study in which all those
contextual factors weren't in place to
actually really highlight the potential
benefit of a whey protein supplement so
so this is one of those studies like I
said you look at it and you're like oh I
kind of want to talk about this to make
sure people aren't going to
over-interpret some of these subgroup
analyses and run with them and make
conclusions that aren't accurate like
sorry I only have proteins that are less
than 80 percent protein by weight
because I know they're better it's like
no they're like almost exactly the same
I'm honestly wondering where they got
those proteins from in the first place
because generally when you see isolates
it's like 90 95 percent plus protein by
weight but I mean even most concentrates
are in the 80s range yeah I don't know
it maybe they were maybe you had some
carbohydrate in there maybe that that
might be a way to do it you know like
there's back in the day the n-c-double-a
said that you couldn't give protein
supplements to athletes for I assume a
reason I don't know what it would
positively be but so what they said was
like I think it was I think the
threshold was 30% it was like Italy and
no more than 30% of the calories can
come from protein in the interest of
safety or amateurism or you know insert
whatever Madlib you want to put in there
and I'm pretty sure they got rid of this
rule but so what they would do is they'd
be like here's the collegiate protein
powder and it was the same protein
powder with like 60 grams of sugar added
to it to try to and to try to add enough
calories that that the protein provided
like 29.9% so some and maybe there was
some some carbohydrate contributions
there dude so I remember when I was
first getting into lifting you know I
was like 14 years old and a dumb ass
like I didn't know anything and a big
guy at the gym told me that oh man it
like if you want to get big if you want
the best protein supplement on the
market you got to go with MA
milk that's like the best thing it has
all this extra stuff in it it's gonna
make You huge so I remember going to the
muscle milk website and looking to see
what their products were and they they
did have like just regular muscle milk
and then a more expensive like muscle
milk Pro and it said on the label
something like you know preferred by in
seed up like the best didn't see double
a football teams or whatever and I
remember looking at the label I was like
this is the same [ __ ] product but
there's like less protein per serving
[ __ ] ton of maltodextrin I'm 14 I don't
know what that is but whatever it's not
protein and it's like 25 percent more
expensive like dude you know supplement
companies [ __ ] love to that rule
because Malto dextran is so much cheaper
than protein but they just throw that in
and then probably are able to make the
product more expensive because they can
say like used by n-c-double-a athletes
you know so yeah for sure so before we
move on in the next study I've got my my
two big take-home points about
meta-analyses number one the beauty of a
meta-analysis is that it gives you a
pooled effect size the magnitude of the
effect is the beauty of the
meta-analysis way too frequently people
get bogged down in the p-value most of
them the power is inflated just because
you've got several studies in the mix
anyway but but the thing is like
especially with these subgroup analyses
it can go the other way where it's like
you only had two in the subgroup it
wasn't going to be significant unless
the effect was enormous so what I would
encourage people to do when you're
looking at a meta-analysis look at the
size of effect as the the most important
thing you're looking at how consistent
is it and then start worrying about the
p-values and all that stuff okay but
don't don't just get caught up in the
p-value and forget to worry about how
big the actual effect was because no one
cares about a super tiny effect with a
p-value of 0.05 it's not doing anything
for you
if the effect is small in the first
place the other take-home point and this
this applies to meta-analyses but also
just about any study in our field where
they measure two groups over time if one
group improves to a significant level
and the other group improves but in a
non significant level based on their
p-values that doesn't mean there was
like an interaction it doesn't mean that
their responses were wildly divergent
right so two groups could respond almost
the same way maybe one group had a
p-value of 0.01 0.06 every now and then
that's a kind of a extreme example but
you'll see people who say wow this one
treatment worked and the other one
totally didn't and with those p-values
their responses were essentially the
same so so when that applies to subgroup
analyses and a lot of other studies in
this field as well look for interaction
tests look for moderator tests those are
what actually tell you if the responses
were indeed divergent in nature yeah and
you still see that even in the published
research show up all the time like every
month everybody I mean it's so that's
not just like you know social media not
being good at interpreting research no
that's that's like very poor
interpretations of research in the
research yes that that gets by peer
review every single month and we'll
probably until we're dead Gregg sweet
yeah all right now Gregg keeps us in a
job yeah now previously you'd talked a
little bit about photo therapy and I
believe you have an update for us about
photo therapy I do so on the last non
Q&A episode of the stronger by science
podcast I talked about photo therapy a
little bit when we recorded that episode
it was I don't know maybe like 36 hours
after I found out how far behind this
body of literature I was and so to be
clear I can turn through a lot of
literature in 36 hours but you know not
even close to an entire body and so
within like 48 hours of recording that
podcast I was
[ __ ] I just learned a lot more stuff
that I wish I would have included so
this is just a really quick update
so just to recap from the last episode
talked about photo therapy and the
things I leaned into the most were that
there is pretty solid and consistent
evidence that photo therapy can improve
acute performance it can improve force
output I wasn't sure why last time I dug
up some more papers it turns out photo
therapy increases intracellular calcium
levels which improves excitation
contraction coupling a little bit so
that largely explains the increase in
force output so that's cool for strength
athletes but then it also just improves
other training performance by
essentially making oxidative metabolism
a little bit more efficient by allowing
oxygen to dissociate from hemoglobin and
myoglobin a little bit more efficiently
in helping a couple of the cytochrome
complexes of the mitochondria function a
little bit more efficiently so it
increases stuff like rep performance or
time to task failure during isometric
tasks really good stuff
another thing that there's quite a bit
of evidence supporting is that it
improves recovery from resistance
exercise so you know things like
decrease in muscle soreness lower levels
of creatine kinase etc etc oh and in
actual improvements in rate of
performance recovery so you know you do
a fatiguing session you test force
output 48 hours later if you had photo
therapy done after the training session
force tends to have recovered a little
bit more in the 24 to 48 hours following
training so that was the stuff that I
had read up on the most prior to the
last time I talked about this and one
thing I noted is that a lot of times
things that improve recovery actually
don't help longitudinal training
outcomes so they don't actually help you
get bigger and stronger and sometimes
they actually go the opposite direction
so you know if you take a high dose of
insets
like non-steroidal anti-inflammatory
drugs before a training session you're
probably not gonna be a sore the next
day or the day after but at least if
you're young and healthy it's probably
gonna compromise strength and
hypertrophy over time there's some
conflicting evidence with older adults
so older adults may actually get more
hypertrophy if they take NSAIDs that's
another discussion for another day
similar with high-dose antioxidants may
help improve recovery a little bit but
also compromise long term training
outcomes same thing with ice baths that
improves especially like functional
recovery so things like force and work
capacity but now we have like three or
four studies showing that that decreases
longitudinal training outcomes so you
can't just assume that's something that
improves recovery actually helps make
you bigger and stronger over time and so
one of the things I noted is that I did
find one study showing that photo
therapy actually improved strength and I
perch free outcomes over time
but I I was kind of more tentative about
that because that was the only study
looking at longitudinal outcomes that I
had come across at that point because
you know when we recorded last time I'd
mostly been reading about the acute
stuff so since then I came across a
review by Farrah resi at all titled
photobiomodulation in human muscle
tissue in advantage in sports
performance question mark and within
this review
they kind of collated and brought
together all of the longitudinal studies
that had been done to that point looking
at the effects of photo therapy on
long-term training outcomes so there
were there were seven in total three of
them aren't all that relevant to us so
one of them was looking at whether doing
photo therapy before or after a training
session was better for long-term
outcomes and it was pretty similar but
that you know it's not comparing photo
therapy to not using photo therapy one
of them looked
at cycle ergometer training so you know
basically cycling training which very
well could be cool and useful to someone
I'm personally not all that interested
probably not super interesting to most
listeners of this podcast but I can just
give you the cliff notes on that it did
improve or it did decrease quadriceps
fatigability during an isokinetic knee
extension test after cycle ergometer
training using photo therapy so you know
that's potentially interesting for
endurance athletes listening to this and
then the other one that again is
probably not all that relevant is one
where the only functional outcome they
were looking at was a vertical jump
performance and the the longitudinal
aspect of the study was two weeks of
training and I don't think you can
really do anything with that so those
were three of the studies there were
four more though that we're looking at
longitudinal outcomes that probably are
useful and interesting to the people
listening to this so the first one is
the Baroni study I mentioned last time
so subjects in that were untrained males
they were doing eccentric knee extension
training for eight weeks and basically
photo therapy helped everything so they
looked at several muscle thickness
measures that increased more in the
photo therapy group 15.4% versus at nine
point four percent they looked at
isometric peak torque of the quads that
increased by twenty and a half percent
versus thirteen point seven percent
again with the larger increase in the
photo therapy group and eccentric peak
torque increased by more as well so
thirty two point two percent versus
twenty percent moving on
there was actually a really cool twin
study performed by the same person who
authored the review fair or se title is
effects of light emitting diode therapy
on muscle hypertrophy gene expression
performance damage and delayed onset
muscle soreness : case control study
with a pair of identical twins so as the
title alludes to the subjects were just
a
of identical twins one of them they both
trained for 12 weeks three times a week
one of them had photo therapy performed
on them after each training session the
other did not leg press
increased in both of these individuals
so in all of these numbers I'm about to
read the larger increase is in the one
that received photo therapy so leg press
increased 53% vs. 28% knee extension one
rep max increased thirty seven percent
versus twenty percent the one receiving
photo therapy had lower creatine kinase
levels throughout the entire study so
that is again a marker a muscle damage
had lower measures of subjective muscle
soreness throughout the study and this
one also assessed hypertrophy they
looked at fie muscle volume which
increased by 20 percent in the one
receiving photo therapy versus five
percent in the one who didn't and they
also looked at some gene expression
stuff so there were larger reductions in
gene expression for interleukin-1 beta
and myostatin in the one receiving photo
therapy so interleukin-1 beta is an
inflammatory marker myostatin is
obviously an inhibitor of muscle
hypertrophy so those gene expression for
both of those genes decreased more in
the one receiving photo therapy and
there was a larger increase in mTOR gene
expression in the twin receiving photo
therapy mTOR again is implicated and
probably the main hypertrophy signaling
cascade do that's wild 20% versus 5%
yeah and so like that's especially
noteworthy because we can't say like oh
maybe it's just like sampling
variability therefore they're identical
twins yeah genetics yeah yes for real so
one thing worth noting is contrary to
popular opinion identical twins aren't
actually genetically identical they were
when like they split in the womb but
people do actually accumulate not just
epigenetic
changes but some degree of genetic
changes over time just due to like gene
damage and whatnot you can have like new
genes inserted by viruses and I think
monozygotic twins also have differences
in like copy number variation even like
when they do split and I didn't know
that that's interesting yeah so so
they're not perfectly identical but you
would still assume not a bad control
though yeah yeah you can still very
safely assume that they're genetically
similar enough that differences in genes
aren't explained a fourfold difference
in hypertrophy you know how like one of
the things we talk about sometimes is
like the new trend is to just
arbitrarily split your sample into
responders and non-responders
yeah you know somewhere on a college
campus a couple twin sign up for a study
you know that at least one time in
history one was a responder and one
wasn't
oh sure because it's always so arbitrary
I'm like what are you actually splitting
yeah okay so that was study number two
number three title is effects of
low-level laser therapy parentheses 808
nanometers close parentheses on physical
strength training in humans subject here
her subjects here were 36 untrained men
they trained leg press for 12 weeks
received laser therapy at the end of
each training session and so one Brett
Max leg press increase 55% in the photo
therapy group versus 26% in the non
photo therapy group they looked at
increase in isokinetic knee extension
peak torque that increased by seven
point three eight percent in the photo
therapy group versus three point one six
percent and the other group they looked
at thigh circumference so I guess they
didn't have that's weird that they had a
dynamometer but not any way to like
directly assess eye perch for you but
whatever they looked at thigh
circumference as a measure of
hypertrophy pretty rough measure but it
is what it is
increased by 4.5 2% in the phototherapy
group versus 2.75 percent in the other
group one thing worth noting is that the
difference in leg press 1 rep max in
this study was statistically significant
the increase in isokinetic torque and
thigh circumference wasn't weren't
significant but I kind of think that's
because they made some weird statistical
choices here so they used a Cruz Cal
Wallis test rather than just like a
two-by-two ANOVA which is weird because
generally you would only use that test
if the assumptions of ANOVA had been
violated and they just said that they
decided they were going to use that
preemptively which is a really weird
thing to do because unless there is a
good reason to not use an ANOVA using a
Cruz called Wallis test is just going to
decrease statistical power so like yeah
and it's not even like it's not even
like a conservative safer option is
right you're losing detailed information
from your data unnecessarily correct
unless you needed to do it yeah it's not
just a matter of like you know choosing
a more conservative post hoc test right
so that decision wasn't explained in the
text just kind of eyeballing some of
these bar graphs all they show is like
pre and post values they don't show like
change and standard deviation of the
change so it's so unless we assume that
the very the variability and the changes
were super crazy I kind of think that
maybe isokinetic knee extension torque
would have been a significant difference
and maybe like circumference wouldn't
have been if they had done in ANOVA but
that's just a kind of like minimally
informed to guess here anyway
weird stats it is what it is but you
know the significant difference again
was in favor of phototherapy and the two
non significant differences also leaned
in favor of phototherapy in that study
and then the fourth one of this group is
by Toma and colleagues title is low
level laser therapy associated with a
strength training
program on muscle performance and
elderly women :
a randomized double-blind control study
this is probably the one that stronger
by science listeners would care about
the least just due to the population
because you know it's elderly women we
know statistically most of you people
are men under 40 like that's that's the
fitness industry if you're a male
content creator we have a lot of female
listeners but not a lot of elderly
female list No so our audience is
absolutely more diverse than just about
everyone else I've talked to yeah but
you know more diverse means we're like
68 percent male instead of 85 right yeah
still like fairly skewed I just want to
let all the ladies listening know that
we appreciate them oh we absolutely do
but yeah so I know that a decent amount
of the audience will care less about
this study however I think this is a
very important study from a scientific
perspective because if you have a
treatment that only works in a very
specific population that tells you that
you know maybe there is only there's
something like physiological
physiologically different about that
population that makes it effective but
maybe it's not as generalizable but so
when you have most of the studies on
healthy young men and then you have
another study on elderly women that is a
very substantially different population
and so if you wind up seeing a similar
effect in that population as well that
lets you know that you know whatever the
treatment is doing is probably you know
going to be more likely to apply to all
humans versus just a specific population
of humans
so very important study so subjects were
48 elderly women they did eight weeks of
leg curls and knee extensions and so in
this study as well they looked at knee
extension one rep max increased by
thirty one point eight percent in the
photo therapy group versus 21 percent in
the other group they also looked at
several isokinetic variables so in like
a
a multi rep test they looked at total
work performed power and peak torque
this study also had weird stats so it
would have been a very ideal study to
you know use like two by two and Nova's
on but or like two by six I guess and so
you had a bunch of different measures
whatever but instead her for all of the
the various measures they just did two
one way ANOVA x' instead of various two
way ANOVA z-- and so they just did like
pre and post and they look to see
whether the groups differed at pre and
looked to see whether they differed at
post which again like you're not going
to be able to get an interaction effect
there to see if like the actual changes
were different so again it's hard to
tell but there were graphs and just kind
of eyeballing the graphs like certainly
the the nominal values of isokinetic
work power and peak torque increased
more in the phototherapy group but since
they didn't actually do the appropriate
statistical tests on like whether those
increases were significantly larger it's
hard to say but they were certainly
nominally larger you know the thing
that's most frustrating about that but
as like let's say you didn't want to do
the two way ANOVA cuz you didn't want to
deal with the interaction and the
theoretical underpinning that requires
some degree of thought right they could
have just done the one way and Cova on
the post and just use the pre values as
a covariant the interpretation would be
just as easy and it's literally just the
click of a button in most software's
it's just so frustrating and in fact
that actually that actually tends to out
perfil outperform a two by two ANOVA
that there has been some simulation
studies where they kind of simulate a
bunch of data sets the the one way an
Cova on post tests using pre tests as
the covariant is in many cases better
but pretty much always at least as good
as the
two-way anova for the four people out
there that are interested in that well
I'll tell you what that's not what they
did that is not what they did so and and
by the way I know I just said almost
always for a stats decision so just
don't yell at me I know you shouldn't
oversimplify like that I'm sure there
are certain scenarios where I'm wrong so
don't yell at me
well of the six people who know what
you're talking about at least one of
them is very upset right now
pretty much yeah okay so the one thing
we can say for sure is the one rep max
knee extension increased more in the
phototherapy group the other measures
again increased nominally more in the
phototherapy group but hard to know if
if those differences were significant so
anyway those were the studies in
aggregate if you look at the measures of
either one rep maxes or like peak torque
values in seven measures across four
studies mean increase was 33.8% in the
phototherapy conditions versus 18.4% in
the other conditions which is almost a
two-fold difference not too shabby
and more than a two-fold difference in
hypertrophy opiate in fewer measures so
three measures across three studies
13.3% versus 5.7% so basically I think I
mean I definitely under sold the amount
of longitudinal studies there were on
phototherapy the last time I talked
about this on the podcast seems pretty
solid one thing worth noting is like for
studies means a lot more than one study
and especially when it's for studies who
all have broadly similar findings you
know so it's it's a general finding that
has now been replicated three times
which is pretty cool with no evidence
against it so that's that's good
certainly more studies would be very
much appreciated because you know even
for very consistent studies it's still
just for studies and the other thing
worth no
all of these studies used untrained
lifters I have to assume that if you did
these studies on trained lifters
certainly like the absolute amount of
improvement in both groups would be
lower I kind of assume that the relative
value that you get from photo therapy
would be smaller as well just because
like it it seems to increase
intracellular calcium that's a good
thing and also like make oxidative
metabolism work a little bit better
those are things that also just change
with resistance training so it is
possible that it wouldn't well I guess
it's possible that it wouldn't do
anything and certainly possible that the
the magnitude of the effect would be
smaller in trained lifters versus
untrained so like that's it that's an
important caveat to point out but just
based on the literature that we do have
this seems really promising it seems
really effective and just kind of
reinforces what I said the last time
like it's surprising to me that no one's
talking about it because I mean it it
seems to improve all aspects of training
it improves performance in the gym it
improves recovery after training and it
helps you get bigger and stronger over
time like I don't know man like I see a
lot of people talking about trivial [ __ ]
that like maybe affects one of those
three things to a much smaller degree do
I know you want to take a swipe at
beta-alanine so just do it
people still talk about beta-alanine why
the [ __ ] do people still talk about
beta-alanine like it doesn't do hardly
anything for for performance like in the
durations that most resistance training
takes place and so like if [ __ ] makes
your skin crawl improves performance by
like 1.4 percent or whatever the [ __ ] it
was in the last meta-analysis and like
people still talk about it like it's a
good thing like I don't know like let's
talk about photo therapy and just shut
the [ __ ] up about beta-alanine let's
just talk about lasers you know I hear
you know it is
prising I mean I remember the first time
on social media I saw somebody doing it
and I was like oh boy here we go again
right I I just immediately because it
looks crazy
the general idea yeah I mean I never
looked into it more cuz like I've known
about this general premise for for a
decade like a physical therapist that
worked with one of the first guys I
trained with like I met him we chatted
for a while he was like oh you should
come down to the clinic at some I was
like dealing with a hamstring strain he
was like you should come down to the
clinic I can get that hamstring to heal
up in half the time I got this laser
it's gonna get your right and like even
as like a [ __ ] 16 year old kid I was
like come the [ __ ] on like it's a laser
like you can't tell me that a laser is
gonna help my hamstring heal faster
turns out it probably can like there's a
pretty large amount of rehab literature
on laser therapy as well but I mean when
I heard about that when I was a gullible
child I was like this has to be [ __ ]
so I think I just never looked into it
more because my first impression was
like there's no way this is true yeah
but it seems like it is that the first
time I saw it it was the person who was
doing it and kind of posting about it
was somebody who does tend to be
susceptible to the newest just absolute
BS on the market right so like it's just
the newest ridiculous supplement and
just all the weird modalities that show
up for six weeks and everybody's doing
them and then you never hear about him
again so I was like oh okay on to the
next on to the next one but no I've been
stunned the more you know we've talked
about this you and I've talked about was
probably three times now and there's
research but they call that science I
guess yeah like apparently it does stuff
it's wild that's cool I mean as I still
I still retain my skepticism of consumer
grade products that I expressed the last
time we talked about this on the podcast
but yeah I mean the more and more I read
about the actual science of it the more
and more Sullivan it I am conceptually
if anyone's listening to this and
they're looking for a reasonably cheap
but possibly impactful study to do do a
validation study on a consumer-grade
phototherapy
product they range anywhere from about a
hundred bucks to 300 bucks you know you
could probably rock that with a
reasonably small grant like in if it
turns out that any of them work really
well man I'm all in in an owl note I
gain nothing from saying any of this I'm
not I'm not in the the pocket of big
laser I just think this is really cool
and I am stunned that I was this
ignorant about it yeah well you weren't
alone
nobody's talking about it one thing that
people do talk about it's carbs that's a
jarring segue silky-smooth yeah so
there's a study it was a meta-analysis
kind of about glycogen replenishment and
this was a study by Macklin at all I had
considered doing it for a mass issue
decided not to and then somebody a
Joshua Hockett actually emailed me and
was like hey have you seen this you
should you should write something about
it so I'll meet you halfway Joshua I'll
talk about it so if you're thinking okay
I don't really care about glycogen
depletion who would it there actually is
some application for a lot of different
people so if you're a power lifter and
you're cutting weight trying to make
weight for a meat there's a decent
likelihood that you might be depleting
your muscle glycogen and might need to
replenish it in a fairly tight
turnaround if you're any kind of sport
athlete certainly doing a vigorous
amounts of exercise high volumes of it
during your competitive season you you
might need to make sure you have your
glycogen repleted for competition
certainly any weight sport athlete that
does a lot of weight reduction and then
bodybuilders you know everybody tries to
micromanage
during peak week one of the things you
really can make a meaningful impact on
is whether your muscles are full of
glycogen or flat and depleted so the
purpose of this semi meta analysis is
more a systematic review the purpose was
to look at the extent of muscle glycogen
depletion through different modes of
exercise and then also to look at
different dietary approaches for
replenishment of depleted glycogen one
of the reasons I wanted to talk about
this was because I thought the
terminology was hilarious so they you
know normally you'll see in a study
they'll be like we called this effect
size trivial and this effect size small
and this effect size moderate well they
put in the huge category which I had
never seen maybe that's a standard thing
I mean I do supplement research so small
is enormous and moderate doesn't happen
when you're talking supplements so I'm
not used to these huge effect sizes
maybe that's the thing but turns out
when you do a very specific glycogen
depletion protocol the effect size on
muscle glycogen levels is technically
huge so that there was no surprise there
but what they did look at with some of
the characteristics of the studies that
caused really big depletion of muscle
glycogen so if you're out there and
you're thinking I want to deplete my
muscle glycogen either because I'm
trying to super compensate for
competition or because I'm just trying
to shed glycogen weight or whatever the
case may be your reason for depletion or
if you're doing exercise like this and
you're wondering will this make me to
plead it that's another way to look at
it usually longer duration stuff and
bouts that include both low and fairly
high intensity work in the middle those
were the ones that really depleted
muscle glycogen so usually the ones that
were over 60 minutes total and had some
really heavy-duty high intensity kind of
spurts within those 60 minutes so if you
think you go on a bike at like a normal
kind of low to moderate steady state
pace have a few bouts mixed in where you
really grind it for a little bit and
then
kind of recover on a lower intensity you
know a little stretch of lower intensity
kind of going back and forth that's
pretty much what you're looking at the
challenge with glycogen depletion is you
need the duration of the of the bout to
be long enough to actually get the job
done and burn through some substrates
you know if you think you're going to go
and do a series of 10-second Sprint's
ain't gonna do it you're gonna burn
through a bunch of phosphocreatine
you're gonna make a bunch of
phosphocreatine you're gonna be going
back and forth obviously you're gonna
you're gonna get some some glycogen
depletion in the process but if you're
trying to maximize your efficiency you
would do this kind of at least an hour
just to make sure you're burning through
that substrate with enough total work to
get the job done
now on the replenishment side of thing
that that's what I find to be most
useful for most people that are
listening they did look a little bit at
single studies that we're comparing
types of carbs so you can look at
complex versus simple carbohydrates so
starch type carbohydrates versus sugars
there's some studies looking at small
molecular weight versus you know larger
molecular weights there are some modest
differences here and there with
individual studies but really I don't
think it makes a lot of sense to to get
bogged down in those granular details I
think the most important things you want
to worry about when you're trying to
restore your glycogen is the timing of
the carb refeed and the amount of the
carb refeed yeah so I'm I'm skeptical
that the small meat small molecular size
is slightly better right that's what you
have here on this outline because I
learned from tea nation that the key to
recovery is the high molecular weight
stuff the highly branched cyclic dextran
which is probably the most sciency
phrase I knew when I was like 17 oh yeah
because of tea nation ads so I am quite
quite honestly shocked to hear that
that's not the most scientifically
rigorous supplement brand on the market
yeah you can find it you can't trust
Biotest who can you trust I don't know
man
you you can find these little individual
studies that might indicate some of
these granular details matter but the
really important factors like the
molecular weight stuff I'm just not that
interested maybe I'm way off base here
but I mean my lab we did a study looking
at carbohydrates of different molecular
weights it didn't matter at all what I
think is most important there is a
post-workout window when we're talking
about glycogen repletion so a lot of
times people have seen these studies
about saying like a post-workout window
doesn't matter those are really looking
at protein for the most part when we do
exercise and we've got our muscles
contracting the glute for trans look the
glute for transport proteins translocate
to the the outer region of the muscle so
they can help bring carbohydrate into
the muscle and stored as glycogen so
that glute for translocation that is a
transient effect it happens in response
to exercise and then it goes away so you
really want to capitalize on that
post-workout period if your interest is
in completely maximizing muscle glycogen
replenishment also during this time
immediately post-workout there's some
additional blood flow to the muscle kind
of residual from the workout that might
facilitate some of that nutrient
delivery so within the first two hours
after a glycogen depleting workout that
that's a really good opportunity to make
sure that you are are getting that
glycogen replenished especially if it's
time-sensitive if you do a depleting
bout and you don't need to use that
muscle group for another 48 hours it
doesn't matter you really don't have to
worry about it but if you're you know
doing this glycogen depleting exercise
and you need to make sure that you're
completely repleted in terms of glycogen
for about that's in 16 hours or 24 hours
then you might want to take a closer
look at it now the common approaches
that they looked at in the studies in
this particular paper they would
basically give a bolus of carbohydrate
every 30 minutes or 60 minutes or two
hours and generally speaking there
wasn't a huge difference between them
but I think one thing to keep in mind is
that glucose and galactose use different
intestinal transporters than fructose
and so what that means is it probably
makes sense to make sure that whatever
carbs you're eating are going to be
broken down and absorbed as a
combination of glucose and galactose and
fructose so glucose transport it's its
absorption in the intestines it maxes
out around 60 grams per hour some people
estimate it to be a little bit higher
than that but for the sake of argument
let's be conservative and say 60 now if
instead of having a pure glucose bolus
of carbohydrate if you had a two-to-one
ratio roughly of glucose to fructose
then you could probably get away with
absorbing 90 grams of carbs per hour so
I think the easiest recommendation would
be shooting for somewhere in the
ballpark of 60 to 90 grams of carbs per
hour you can have a bolus roughly each
hour or you can have a bolus twice as
big every two hours that should be
enough to get the job done and I think
leaning toward a roughly two to one
ratio of glucose to fructose makes a lot
of sense and then certainly it can be a
mixture of starches and sugars and and
all that stuff but generally speaking
you want some degree of glucose some
degree of fructose ideally somewhere
near a two-to-one ratio another fun fact
about glycogen repletion is that
caffeine can actually help a little bit
it's not gonna make or break your
glycogen load but caffeine can be useful
which leads me to another paper recently
but I'm not gonna get too much too far
into the details on this one but did you
have something to say about glycogen I
had something to say about Biotest
okay what do you guys so dude I forgot
how ridiculous this product was so if
you're if you're old like us and you
were on the internet with
the Anaconda protocol dropped that's
what that's what all the memes were
about just because like you can't tell
me that that wasn't intentionally sexual
that that was one of the most ridiculous
marketing campaigns ever I forgot just
how I mean whatever like if they can get
people to pay the price like market sets
the rates whatever I get that but I
forgot just how much of a ripoff plasma
was so that's where that's where they
were talking about the benefits of
highly branched cyclic dextran all the
time so tracks just tell me what would
you pay for a reactive a reactive pump
activator a brutal workout formula if
you will which perserving
has 38 grams of carbs 15 grams of
protein a little citrulline malate and a
little beating
I mean 75 cents per serving maybe a
dollar
how does 70 bucks for 20 serving sound
that's higher than I got about two and a
half bucks per serving yeah it's a
little above what I was putting on the
table that's outrageous I spent yeah I
mean how much is a little citrulline I
don't know dirt cheap I mean I mean what
was the dose to say it's in a
proprietary blend so it's not listed so
you know it's not much I mean the the
proprietary blend includes the protein
and carbohydrate so that that's where
can I math that's where that's 53 grams
of a 65 gram total formula so I mean
like some of the some of the things here
at the end like magnesium citrate tri
basic sodium like there's probably not
that much of that so it might be
appropriately dosed citrulline malate
and betaine even though I am still
skeptical because it is a proprietary
but I mean just the fact that you know
it's 65 grams per serving and close to
two-thirds of that is carbohydrate and
it's two and a half bucks of serving
that's wild
yeah well you know it's a stand up
company these are good people so we
don't want to disparage their name or
their product I'm sure it's I'm sure
it's terrific
sure sure sure perfect okay now I had a
really good segue and you just stomped
all over it with this insertion coffee
coffee yeah there you go
so like I was saying after after reading
so much bio test sales copy boy am I
tired I could do with a stiff cup of joe
take it away
perfect thank you so there's a recent
paper by Pickering and Gurjit the title
is is coffee a useful source of caffeine
pre exercise and basically what they
what they concluded I'm jumping right to
the highlights here they said there's
limited evidence that caffeinated coffee
has the potential to offer
Urgo Janke effects similar to those of
caffeine anhydrous which is basically
just supplemental caffeine at first i
read that and i thought they were saying
like that there's a lack of evidence i
think with what they're getting at is
there is some evidence but it'd be great
if there were more that there aren't
that many studies looking at coffee
specifically as an ergogenic aid but
what we have would indicate that it is
pretty equivalent in terms of its
ergonomic effects and what they also
noted was that co ingesting caffeine
with decaffeinated coffee so if for some
reason a person in the world were
inclined to have decaf coffee and mix
some caffeine into it
the decaffeinated coffee does not
detract from the ergogenic effects of
the caffeine now the only reason I bring
this up we've talked about caffeine
plenty on the podcast the reason I bring
it up is nerds like Greg will always
talk about you know it's just a single
study let's wait and make sure it gets
replicas
and all that stuff right a single study
you don't want to get too carried away
this is a perfect example so in 1998
Gramm at all did a study and they tested
several different treatments it was a
placebo a caffeine capsule alone regular
coffee with caffeine in it just a normal
cup of coffee decaf coffee and then the
final treatment was decaf coffee with a
caffeine capsule okay all of the
treatments aside from the placebo
obviously and the decaf coffee provided
four point four five milligrams per
kilogram of caffeine it's a pretty
standard
arrghh agenda caffeine dose the only
group out of all of those that improved
was water plus a caffeine capsule so the
regular coffee didn't work and the decaf
with the caffeine capsule also didn't
work and so what they theorized was that
something in the coffee was inhibiting
the beneficial effects of caffeine and
they thought maybe it was the
chlorogenic acids but I mean with coffee
it's like take your pick there's like
hundreds of bioactive compounds in it we
essentially ran with that conclusion for
like 15 years to the to the point that
as late as like 2010 in review papers
they would say like yeah if you want to
get it organic effect it can't be from
coffee you got to get the good stuff the
caffeine anhydrous so this is like a
real world example of where for I think
about 15 years we took this one study
and said well looks fine to me and just
went with it and then it wasn't really
until 2013 that a few studies started
reinvestigating that question and it
kind of just went the other direction
you know there's still we could
certainly use more data related to this
particular question but from what we
have in the last few years there have
been more studies coming out there's one
by Hodgson at all there was one by
Richardson and Clark my lab group did a
paper on the topic and generally
speaking what we find was some of this
more recent research is that caffeinated
coffee seems to be
just fine in comparison to a caffeine
supplement which intuitively makes sense
but is actually a controversial take or
at least it was up until about a couple
years ago so this is a real world world
example of when people like Greg want to
be a stick in the mud and they say
hold your horses let's see if that
actually replicates this is an example
of that however I will note that
Pickering and girge ik in this paper
they bring up some good points there are
some challenges with coffee if you're
using coffee and trying to get our genic
doses of caffeine sometimes that
requires you to ingest a pretty high
volume of fluid so for some people that
might be annoying pre-workout having a
bunch of coffee obviously you can go to
some you know more concentrated coffee
type products with higher caffeine
content but another thing to keep in
mind is variability of caffeine content
so the type of being how it's roasted
how finally it's ground how its prepared
all of these things go into the actual
caffeine content of the coffee you're
drinking so if you're trying to get an
exact orogenic dose for a really big
competition that's something to keep in
mind and a great example that is a study
by mckusker at all they got the same
product from a coffee shop six days in a
row so same product same location with
Starbucks right I believe so yeah and of
those six days the lowest caffeine
content of this product was 259
milligrams and the highest was 564 so
that's a hell of a range I mean that
those are two very different experiences
from that cup of coffee right so it's
something to keep in mind if you're
gonna use coffee as a regular orga genic
aid I do you know I think it's fine but
if you're like let's say it's a day one
of the Olympic Trials and you're trying
to make sure you've got your your
caffeine dose perfectly titrated then it
might make sense to go with something
else brand new study that is not super
relevant but I found it fascinating
not like a week or two ago by Fukuda the
title is habitual coffee drinkers may
present conditioned responses from
coffee cue and this was a study in I
believe it was in the field of
psychology this isn't like a performance
Fitness type thing but I found it
interesting the sight and smell of
coffee alone they didn't ingest any of
it they basically were just like okay
smell it you see it here's some coffee
take it away that alone appeared to
enhance performance on a simple reaction
time task in habitual coffee drinkers so
it was one of those things where if you
believe that your love for coffee has
gotten to the point where simply being
in its presence is a positive thing for
you apparently these people got a
benefit from just smelling and seeing it
all right and there was one more study
that I wanted to talk about so the title
of which is which specific modes of
exercise training are most effective for
treating low back pain Network
meta-analysis by Owen at all and so
essentially what this was doing is
looking to see what sort of
interventions and therapies helped with
various things associated with low back
pain and then also which therapies were
more or less effective so they looked at
things like what most helps with pain
what most improves physical function and
what most improves mental health because
people with chronic pain conditions
often find themselves in a pretty dark
mental place as well and so that's what
they were trying to do not just to see
if these things work but which things
work better than others and so as far as
pain goes Pilates actually was the
runaway number one so they they did some
statistics like based on the results of
the meta-analysis to see what the odds
were that each particular treatment was
the most effective and least effective
so I'm gonna go down and so like that
has to do
both the effect size estimate and also
the variability so for example something
if there's two treatments and one has a
slightly larger effect size but it's a
more highly variable it may have a
slightly lower mi you may have slightly
lower odds of being the best treatment
than something with a slightly lower
mean effect size but much smaller
variability so I'm doing this by
likelihood of something being the best
not just what had the largest effect
size so it it's kind of like a dual
measure of effect size and consistency
of the effect so as far as pain goes
Pilates seemed to be the runaway number
one most effective thing it was like a
68% chance or so that it was the best
therapy of the ones included in this
meta-analysis other ones that did quite
well were aerobic exercise and so that
was number two and then roughly tied for
third were stabilization exercises and
resistance exercise moving on to
physical function the most effective was
resistance training followed by
stabilization exercise and water based
exercise roughly tied for second place
with yoga in I guess fourth place
because there was a two-way tie for a
second and then aerobic exercise and
Pilates were also quite effective for
physical function as well and from a
mental health perspective the most
effective seemed to be resistance
training followed closely by aerobic
training with Pilates in a somewhat
distant third so things just to mention
about this is the type of exercise that
most people would do like when most
people think oh I'm gonna go work out
they're either thinking I'm gonna go
lift some weights or I'm gonna go for a
run like those seem to be the most
common types of like quote unquote
workouts that people do and aerobic
exercise and resistance exercise we're
both among the most effective treatments
for pain physical function
and mental health so you know if you're
dealing with low back pain and you're
thinking should I go to the gym and do
some sort of gym thing the answer is
probably yes
Pilates also seemed to do quite well it
showed up on all three also so you know
I mean I'm biased I was about to say so
like if your mom or dad is dealing with
low back pain and they're like ah should
I do Pilates say sure but I mean if
you're dealing with low back pain and
you're thinking should I do Pilates sure
like that's all that also seems to be a
very very good option but yeah so kind
of depending on what you're interested
in resistance training maybe is the most
robust it seems to improve both physical
function and mental health the most
pilates seems to be much much more for
just like pain itself but really I would
say those three have the most support
but and I think this is the most
important thing just get moving so again
those were kind of ranked by odds of
being the best therapy of all of the
ones included in the meta-analysis but
you can pull up the full text of this
and look at the effect sizes the effect
sizes for all three of of those outcomes
pain physical function and mental health
for virtually all of the exercise types
were large effects so we're talking
really anywhere between like the Cohen's
D of 0.7 which is like a moderate effect
but close to a large effect up to about
like 1.3 1.4 so like really meaty effect
sizes for all of the outcomes for all of
the various types of exercise so really
you can't go wrong it's you're you're
choosing it's like are you choosing the
best of a lot of good options it's not
like these are good options and the rest
are [ __ ]
but so anything that got people moving
was great however all of the controlled
conditions weren't that good so with low
back pain or really any type of pain
generally it tends to improve over time
you're just dealing with regret
regression to the mean
but in terms of
of how the control conditions worked
either if it's a true control a passive
control which is like you know just
getting advice from a physical therapist
who doesn't actually lay hands on you or
and I think this is the most important
one hands on control conditions in these
studies so that would include stuff like
manual therapy or chiropractic which a
lot of people do go towards for
treatment of low back pain those things
weren't nearly as effective as any kind
of exercise so this is something that's
pretty important because a lot of times
when people are in pain they develop
kanessa phobia like they just stop
moving and I mean there are probably not
advisable ways to move if you're dealing
with low back pain like if you find that
say max triples on the deadlift tend to
aggravate your back and you're dealing
with low back pain you should get out
and move but maybe don't pull max
triples you know but kind of within
reason you get moving and that tends to
help things a lot stuff like manual
therapy and chiropractic maybe it's
better than nothing but that's not much
of an endorsement the the effect sizes
they're just massively paled in
comparison to any type of exercise so I
think that's the biggest takeaway you
know like maybe if the biggest issue
with your low back pain is just the pain
itself yeah go for Pilates maybe if you
know the biggest problems it's causing
you or decrements and physical function
or decrements and mental health yeah I
maybe go for a resistance training but
for the most part just get moving and
that's gonna that's gonna make things
better and don't try to rely on just
manual therapy and chiropractic to fix
it it's probably not going to be nearly
as effective as exercise would be let me
ask a quick follow-up for that you
mentioned that for all the exercise
interventions the effect sizes were
pretty pretty big or any of them
scientifically considered huge no they
weren't so giving you an actual answer
to a joke question like I said they were
all pretty
and like the point 7 to 1.4 range that's
pretty good yeah for sure
alright well I think that does it for
today's episode I believe we've fatigued
the audience we've outstayed our welcome
this is probably time to wrap it up to
play us out I do want to remind the
listeners that we have our biggest sale
of the year going on the the big Black
Friday sale for mass is going on
November 25th to December 2nd and
remember the huge percentage of the
proceeds of that sale go to the American
Foundation for Suicide Prevention really
really good charity they get a hundred
percent of the profit from the new
subscribers we get during the sale along
with 50% of the profit from current
subscribers so it's a great time to get
a good a good price on a mass
subscription and you can feel good about
knowing that a big proportion of that is
going to charity so that does it for
today's episode we've got on the other
side of the music we've got an interview
with Ben [ __ ] we talked to him about
power building basically the the fusion
of powerlifting and bodybuilding for
people who are in who have both you know
lofty physique goals and lofty
powerlifting goals we also talked about
physical culture a little bit of a
change of pace for for our podcasts but
Ben did his PhD studying physical
culture and talks to us all about
specifically the history of physical
culture it was a really really
interesting conversation so we hope
you'll enjoy it as always thanks for
listening and we'll talk to you next
week
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to the stronger by science
podcast today we have a special treat we
are joined by Ben [ __ ] Ben thank you
so much for coming on the show thanks
for having me so Ben for any of our
listeners who are not already familiar
with you and your work do you mind
giving us a brief description of who you
are and what you do sure I Who am I I
guess that's a tough question but I am a
physical culture historian and
professional power lifter I guess you
could say I've kind of forged my own
path and you know currently what I do is
compete in both powerlifting and
bodybuilding now and I coached mathletes
I do a lot of social media writing and
other types of content and on the side I
also do some academic work related to
the history of physical culture which
encompasses not just strength sports but
really anything that people do to make
themselves more fit or more capable of
performing in athletic events or even in
their daily lives and you did your PhD
in in a physical culture program at the
University of Texas right correct or is
there any analogous program to that
whenever I think physical culture that's
the one that comes to mind are there
other programs like it across the
country there are but they're pretty few
and far between it's a rather niche
program as you can imagine and the
selection of schools that you have to
study that sort of thing is rather
limited are are you still doing your
research at Texas or have you branched
out on your own at this point I branched
out on my own I my fiance and I recently
moved to Virginia actually it's been a
full year now and so I'm no longer at
Texas at all though I do hope to return
in one place yeah it's so been on the
powerlifting side of things it seems
like you write a lot for elite FTS is
that right yeah I write for actually a
lot of sites elite FTS barb and I also
write for I've done a little a little
bit of stuff for Kabuki strength some
other you know
one off stuff I think garage gym I did
something for and similar sites like
that so I really enjoy the writing
process and I've been pretty prolific in
that area awesome so I would imagine a
lot of our listeners have read your your
writing before and if they haven't
hopefully they'll check it out
after this episode so today obviously
because your background we certainly
want to talk a lot about physical
culture because you have a very unique
perspective on that given how much you
have studied it but before we do that
you mentioned that you compete in both
powerlifting and bodybuilding so you're
one of those few people that really
embraces that hybrid position where you
do a little bit of both do you see
yourself as basically 50/50 or are you
more of a power lifter or more of a
bodybuilder yeah not even close to 50/50
it's more like ninety ten I I don't
really enjoy bodybuilding at all but I
do you know seem to be able to stay lean
fairly easily and over the course of my
power lifting career I've added enough
muscle mass that I can do decently and
embody building with a little bit of
work for the areas that are neglected
with typical powerlifting training but
you know is really the the reason I
stepped into bodybuilding in the first
place was to give my body a break from
you know the strain of the heavy weights
my body in my mind so the first time you
dieded were you surprised by how much it
sucks getting like stage lean not to
like the last three weeks and honestly I
think I over dieded for that point I
think you know had I stopped three weeks
out and just started maintaining I could
have looked a lot better on stage yeah
I've definitely been there it's the
thing is if you're a relatively intense
person or a very focused person it's so
easy to fall into that if like well I'm
already here I might as well just push
and push and push given that you do a
little bit of both you've got some power
lifting and some bodybuilding how do you
generally set up a power building
program I mean I would imagine just
because of what you've accomplished on
both sides of that spectrum a lot of
people come to you saying I want to do
the same thing I want to have a strong
squat bench and deadlift but I also want
to look like a bodybuilder how do you
begin putting together a program like
that for somebody you're right I do get
a lot of people asking that question and
it's really challenging for me because
you know I spent probably the first god
I started training in 2000 2005 maybe
2001 and so for the first decade of
training I was only focused on this quad
bench and deadlift and added a lot of
strength of those movements so then when
it comes time to add in the accessory
work that's gonna build up the points
that don't get a lot of work from those
which are typically you know stuff like
these from these calves arm shoulders
that sort of thing
you can add it in without really
interfering with your training because
you've already built that solid base but
I get so many people asking you know
they just want to jump in without having
that base and it's virtually impossible
and so I really really push them hard to
just focus on powerlifting until they
have a sufficient level of strength to
really support the muscle mass that they
need in order to reach those goals
you know when I'm programming for myself
it's much different again because I
don't need a lot of work for muscles
that for the bigger muscles right a lot
of hypertrophy focus work so I can
afford to build my program around the
main lifts and variations of the main
lifts and then I'll add in you know
currently have a couple extra days for
my shoulders and arms where really I'm
good mostly band work sets of you know
50 or 100 reps just trying to get some
blood through that muscle to really
focus on building the muscle volume but
not really concerned about strength at
all so you basically kind of view it in
stages where where you bring somebody in
who has both these goals and you say
well well let's just kind of focus on
the powerlifting side for a while and
build a base in the praat in the process
and then we'll start working on refining
some of the details associated with
bodybuilding absolutely absolutely it's
really really hard to convince people
that really hard but I very strongly
believe that so I mean about how long of
a buy-in do you do you typically ask if
people because because I could imagine
people are quite impatient with that
yeah and it really depends on the
individual you know because some people
do have a very good strength base built
already and then you know maybe you need
a couple months of polishing up
technique other people who are raw
beginners might need five years of
focusing purely
strength until they have that base built
so it's extraordinarily individual it's
almost completely individual but at the
same time you know typically what I tell
people is okay give the strength in
three months because I think three
months is kind of the minimum you need
to see you need to put in two in order
to see decent strength gains and a lot
of times what happens is people will
start training that way but fine it's
really enjoyable they find the they're
seeing progress almost on a day-to-day
basis and they'll kind of it'll be
easier to convince them okay let's stick
on this route for a little bit longer
yeah that makes sense
I'm just curious here do you know of of
many other people who've kind of taken
the same route through powerlifting and
then bodybuilding that you have because
just right off the top of my head I can
think of several people who were like
fairly successful bodybuilders or at
least like you know did hypertrophy
focused training for a long time got
super jacked and then tried to
transition to powerlifting and did quite
well but I I can't think of that many
people right off the top of my head who
you know started on the powerlifting
side of things and then went on to be
successful in bodybuilding that very
well it's probably just blindness on my
part because I don't follow bodybuilding
that closely so like when someone slips
out of powerlifting and gets into the
bodybuilding world they just kind of
fall off my radar but can you think of
any other people just right off the top
of my head who have been successful
taking the same route you have I mean it
really depends on what you mean by
powerlifting people love to claim that
you know Ronnie Coleman was the ultimate
power builder because he did a few
powerlifting means but that was never
really his you know main focus right and
so it's really hard to say okay how many
elite power lifters have done this and
off the top of my head I don't know a
whole lot I think honestly I think if
you're gonna train to be that high of a
level of power lifter it can be you know
at least for me it was pretty mentally
exhausting thinking okay now I
essentially have to start from scratch
learning an entirely new sport or yeah
maybe I have a little bit of leg up from
the 15 plus years I put it into this but
it's a little bit compared to these
other guys who you know whether they've
just been genetically gifted or they've
been training him different style for
longer or whatever the case might be you
know they're way ahead of me relatively
now that that makes a ton of sense so
you think it's more there aren't that
many people who've been successful going
the direction you have mostly just for
for psychological reasons more so than
like physical reasons yeah and I don't
have a lot of data to support that but
that's kind of my opinion from front of
the people that I've talked to and from
my own experience and again I think you
mentioned this but the other way around
it's much different you know you start
off with bodybuilding I think picking up
powerlifting is maybe a little bit
easier but I haven't had that
perspective so I can't say for sure no I
got you that that makes that makes a ton
of sense I just hadn't really heard that
perspective before but I mean now that
you explained it it makes all the sense
in the world I wonder if you guys know
Johnny Jackson used to train with branch
Warren a lot did he start in
powerlifting because I know he used to
hit the big three pretty hard I I
believe he did I'm not sure though
yeah I'm not really sure either I think
his best deadlift was something like 800
which is a great deadlift but at 275
again it's not really elite level so oh
yeah yeah definitely definitely
so you've competed in both it's not just
like hey I'd like to be kind of good at
both I mean you've competed in
powerlifting competed in bodybuilding
and so as you approach one competition
you know whether it's a powerlifting one
or a bodybuilding one do you start to
shift your training to be basically just
pure powerlifting or pure bodybuilding
or do you continue to train as if it's
kind of a hybrid thing even won
competitions approach it depends on how
close you are in the competition I think
you know for powerlifting is definitely
beneficial to keep some of the I but the
some of the higher rep work I don't want
to say hypertrophy focus or some of the
higher rep work and even in the later
stages of prep because it's very
important to focus on that balance you
know for me if I'm not training my outer
quads well I know my knees are gonna
start hurting because I have a tendency
I flat feet and I have a tendency to let
my VMO take over and so if I'm not
specifically addressing that
a group well it's gonna it's gonna lead
to problems the opposite is also true I
think you know I think in bodybuilding
if you're dropping all of your heavy
movements as soon as you start prep I
think you're probably going to lose too
much size dieting again I don't have
nearly as much experience in the
bodybuilding world and I can't say that
for sure but that was kind of my
impression I wish that I had trained a
little bit heavier during prep and not
dyed it so hard to be honest with you
but again in the very late stages of
either you know say you're 3 to 4 weeks
out of a meet or a show I do think you
have to focus exclusively on one or the
other
yeah I mean at a certain point you
there's just that need for
specialization you know in that you know
that last month maybe six weeks leading
in now one of the interesting things
about people who do both bodybuilding
and powerlifting in full disclosure I
have competed in both but I was a
bodybuilder who did powerlifting to stay
busy
basically so kind of be inverse of of
your perspective but lately in the field
of exercise science there's been there's
been a couple kind of like opinion
papers out that have argued that
essentially the change in muscle mass
over one's lifting career is not
correlated with the change in strength
over that career or more specifically
over the context of maybe a study you
know a few months of training that the
change in muscle size is not related to
the change in strength as someone who
has you know been involved with both
hypertrophy training and powerlifting
well what's your take on that general
concept you know I'm probably gonna
defer to this answer quite a bit
throughout the interview but I think
it's entirely individual personally and
I hope you guys don't take offense to
this but even coming from an academic
background I put almost the zero weight
on academic studies because I know how
sloppily designed how poorly executed
and how limited
their applications can be in the real
world and so I it really kills me when
somebody you know says that something
doesn't work because they've read a
paper that said the contrary and in this
case you know you mentioned within the
scope of a study you know it didn't make
a big difference but if you have a guy
who's training for three months he's not
gonna make that much progress no matter
what compared to a guy who's been
trained in thirty years and so I do
think there are certainly individuals
who you know can add a ton of muscle
mass without ever training heavy and the
opposite is true too right you can add a
ton of strength without ever adding a
lot of muscle but I think for the vast
majority of people they're gonna be
pretty correlated yeah I mean that
that's the thing that kills me as well
like strength can change pretty
substantially in a few months especially
if you're working with untrained lifters
but like muscle size even even if you're
dealing with completely untrained folks
like there may be some some visual
changes in how much muscle someone has
on their frame but if you're talking
like you know how many actual
millimeters of quad thickness did they
add it's not that much so you're
essentially dealing with really small
changes that have a a reasonably
substantial degree of measurement error
and you're looking to see like does this
do these small changes in a noisy
measurement correlate with something
else and I don't think it should shock
anyone that sometimes the correlation is
relatively poor like just knowing the
measurements and the magnitude of
changes you're dealing with it's
shocking that the correlations are even
weaker than they are you know yes
absolutely I totally agree yeah I mean
you know I come from that world of
carrying out you know exercise and
nutrition studies and in controlled lab
lab environments and you know if I do a
study and the results conflict with what
we observe day in and day out in the
real world my first question is
basically what's wrong with our
measurement or our design it's not well
clearly the whole world
around me is crumbling but this study
captured the real truth you know what I
mean I feel like that's one of those
things where if you have a particular
study design or research paradigm that
doesn't seem to be reflecting what
everyone is observing in the trenches
it's probably more important to reflect
about what might be flawed in the
paradigm rather than is it possible that
everything I thought I understood about
muscle and strength was wrong so it's
kind of that that same thing that you
said of like there's a lot of these
studies with with severe limitations
that people often take it in isolation
and treat it as an undeniable fact when
in reality there's there's quite a bit
of nuance to to suss out with any
particular study or or even collection
of studies now let's let's bring it back
to the trenches one of the things I
thought was cool when I first started
messing around with powerlifting after
doing years of bodybuilding was
powerlifting taught me a little bit that
I could take back to my bodybuilding
training in the future I thought
powerlifting in a wave made me a better
bodybuilder what do you think is
something that most bodybuilders would
benefit from adopting when it comes to
how power lifters train I think the
level of effort that you're putting into
the training is far far far greater in
powerlifting I really do even having
gone through a pretty intense prep you
know it's hard to push yourself when
you're dieting very very hard and in
those cases I can see you know the
chances of injured go up your fatigue
levels so high sure you're not gonna
train all-out that but I see up almost
every bodybuilder in my gym they train
like that year-round and I think when
you're in the offseason and you're
rested and you're fresh and again plenty
calories and if you're not training
heavy you're doing yourself a major to
service a major to service and most
bodybuilders you know think they can
train the same year-round and make
progress and maybe they can make
progress but I think they would make far
greater progress if they actually
learned how to train hard and heavy when
appropriate going harder going heavier
now now what about the inverse do you
think there's anything that power
lifters can stand to gain
if borrowing some concepts or some
lessons from from body builder training
yeah
it's almost it's almost exactly the same
but you know sometimes you'll have power
lifters you start dieting when they know
they need to make weight for a show and
they just eat like total crap the rest a
year and it's just like why it doesn't
make sense to me you're giving up so
much potential recovery you know health
benefits muscular what sorry I'm kind of
fired up now in some way my words aren't
coming to me but your body composition
could be so much better and all it takes
is you know not eating junk it day in
and day out but I think a lot of power
lifters think oh well you know I don't
have to look pretty and so they almost
use it as an excuse to eat like crap so
so basically bodybuilders should be
training more like power lifters and
power lifters should be eating more like
bodybuilders
that's my if I had to pick two you know
overarching theme so it would definitely
be the case
those would definitely be the two MUNs
know obviously you can get into a lot of
nuance here I mean for example you know
if you're saying okay you gotta train
hard and heavy if you're a bodybuilder
in the offseason well maybe but maybe
you're not gonna benefit that much from
doing heavy squats or heavy deadlifts
depending on what the case may be you
know what your goals are what your
strength levels are how your body
responds and you know maybe you're a
power lifter who you know focus jersey
clean but you know you focus only on a
squat bench deadlift and you would
really be benefited by doing some
isolation work for certain muscle groups
I mentioned my outer quads and how much
I've benefited just from training those
which was shocking to me but the ability
to activate those muscle groups has
really made a big difference in my
compound lives so this is very out of
left field but I'm genuinely curious
what uh what you do to specifically
train your outer quads so as someone who
doesn't have flat feet I kind of feel
like if I do quad work it just trains
all of my quads kind of similarly and
I've heard about people too I've heard
people talk about isolating certain
heads of their quads certain ways and I
feel like I've tried ever
and everything just feels like just
normal quad work if I I'm curious what
you do to target your outer quads so for
me it's mostly dealing with foot
position and I like to use machines so
that I can really focus on the movement
all right I'm skewed excuse me on the
muscle I'm out of the movement because
if I'm doing squats I can cue that in my
head and I can get a little bit in there
but it's pretty hard cuz you got to
focus on stabilizing the weight and
moving the weight whereas if I'm on a
leg press well it's like I can use a
super controlled negative and I can make
sure that I'm keeping my foot position
perfect where I've got my feet pretty
wide for me right and if you've seen me
squat you know I swap pretty darn narrow
so pretty wide for me I've also got my
toes pointed pretty far in and I'm
really trying to spread the platform
which again you know those are typical
cues that you would use in a squat but
for me those really left a lot out
because you know I honestly think is the
flat foot maybe the weak duck ters and
that led to knee pain for me for that
kept me out of the US Open last year so
for me that's what works again so I'm
such a big proponent of individuality in
both sports that I hesitate to make any
blanket recommendations for me it's much
easier to work with somebody in person
so I can see what their movement
patterns look like and how they might
need to change those to target different
muscle groups know that that makes a lot
of sense I I mean I I wasn't looking for
like a general recommendation for vielle
training I was just genuinely curious
because that's not something I've ever
personally experienced so just building
off those prior two questions that Trek
that Trek's asked you know what power
lifters could learn from body builders
and what body builders could learn from
power lifters as someone with kind of a
foot in both communities what are some
just general misconceptions you see on
both sides of the aisle like what are
things that you see a lot of
bodybuilders believing about power
lifters that just aren't true and
conversely what are some misconceptions
that power lifters have about body
builders well you know for the biggest
misconception I had about body builders
before I started
meaning was that they were all kind of I
hate to use this word but prima donnas
guess we okay we're you know there's a
lot of rivalry and they're not there's
no real sense community and it's
everybody wants to one-up the other guy
and at my experience that both shows
that I did completely untrue everyone
was super supportive everybody is kind
of in the same boat suffering together
and so there's a lot a lot of support
that you get from the community and
bodybuilding it's really really awesome
so that was my personal biggest
misconception the other was that
bodybuilding is pretty easy and I do
think in offseason if you train like a
typical bodybuilder it's pretty darn
easy
but I think if you train hard and you
diet hard when you're dieting
bodybuilding is pretty darn hard just as
hard as powerlifting from the flip side
is you know it's really hard for me to
to say because I started out as a part
of the through my background is entirely
in strength and so I just don't have the
perspective if I had to guess it'd be
that all power lifters are fat and you
know nowadays you know that's not true
there's a lot more competition in the
lower weight classes I mean you can look
at your a belkin who you know as we're
recording this Eastham become compete in
the big dogs tomorrow against some of
the hugest guys and your is relatively
slim for for somebody putting up those
types of numbers
I feel like URI is just trolling
everyone like dude goes to 42 at every
meet in ways like 224 like what the [ __ ]
URI just cut to 220 stop making everyone
else feel bad I've heard he moved all
the way up to like 228 to this oh [ __ ]
he's bullying hard yeah Jesus Christ
he's a monster
yes all right then so we picked your
brain about training a little bit now we
want to talk to you about the other
aspect here which is the physical
culture so we mentioned earlier that you
did your PhD studying physical culture
so I guess the first question is why
pursue physical culture as an academic
pursuit why is that important to you
actually if I could interject just
something more basic than that I feel
like physical culture isn't
term that's used as often as it used to
be so just just so all of the listeners
are on the same page here how would you
define physical culture first off um so
personally when I define physical
culture ah tell people exercise that's
kind of not a great definition by any
means if you were to get an academic
definition you know I believe don't
quote me on this but I believe what my
advisor and her husband Janna Terry Todd
came up with was that physical cultures
any sort of purposeful activity that
people do to improve their lives or
their academic performance and I think
the important thing to remember there is
purposeful right it's not walking the
dog it's something that you're doing
specifically to make yourself more fit
to feel better in your daily life or to
perform better or your chosen sport but
it's also separate from sport right so
it's not you know basketball wouldn't be
considered physical culture that gets
kind of tricky when you then talk about
well as powerlifting a sport is
bodybuilding sport because those
generally do fall under the umbrella
physical culture and when you get in
academia the arguments about definitions
of certain terms can go on and on and on
and I don't like to get into that sort
of nuance but that that would be my best
kind of summary at a high level make
sense to me yeah and now that we've got
a working definition what why pursue it
as an academic pursuit why is it
important to you I'm really fell into a
man so I was I was working at Google
when I applied to go to school Texas and
I got my undergrad degree in finance and
information technology from the
University of Virginia and I worked for
a few years and finally landed this job
at Google and I'd always wanted to work
there because I'm a bit of a nerd I you
know you see all the the you read the
articles and you see the movies and you
think it's just this dream place to work
so I get there and I find out I'm not
all that happy there I need to you know
need a change of pace and so I had
always plan to go to business school and
so I was looking at different programs
and the universe and you know I was
training at the time I started training
in high school for wrestling and so
sport was a passion of mine I thought
you know maybe I could combine
these things get into sport in some way
but still use the management skills that
I had from my my undergrad degree and
hopefully from my MBA and so Texas has a
very good kinesiology program in general
including their MBA with a focus on
sport studies and so while I was
browsing the Texas website I found my
future advisors biography Jan Todd and
if you guys don't know about her she was
like the world's strongest woman she was
one of the very first female power
lifters ever she has hundreds and
hundreds of accolades and fitness she
runs the Arnold strongman Classic every
year in March in Ohio and so she's very
very active in the industry and I found
her biography I was like wow I want to
work with this person so I call her up
and I tell her hey you know I'm applying
the MBA program as hoping if I get in
that I can do some research with you on
the side well Jane has very strong
personality and so Jen basically said
you know forget the MBA just come work
for me build me at first no I had this
plan and she just slowly cooks me along
the way she was like well you know why
don't you submit your resume just so we
haven't file in case you change your
mind so I do that she's like well you
know why don't you take the GRE it's
just we have your scores in case sure
it's no big deal it doesn't cost much
and so I do that and she's like well you
know I think we could probably get some
scholarships for fun and so she just
kind of you know pushes gently gently
gently until finally I buy in and once I
do I realize it's absolutely the right
fit for me because it's really doing
what I love not what you know I thought
I was gonna make money at or thought you
know I was supposed to do that's one
thing so just out of curiosity if you
you know if you weren't then Pollock and
a world-class power lifter and Instagram
famous and a prolific writer how does
one how does one apply a physical
culture degree just out of curiosity you
teach other people to study physical
culture so now that we kind of have the
groundwork laid why study physical
culture what is it in the first place
kind of going all the
way back what are some of the roots of
physical culture in the West which is
probably what would apply to most of the
people listening to this and then what
are some like major physical culture
traditions elsewhere in the world that
are you know maybe really cool but most
listeners wouldn't be aware of so the
first and they answer the first question
I think is pretty cool because the roots
of physical culture in the West are very
deeply tied to religion and so actually
if you trace the trace the history of it
in America at least you know there was a
strong tradition of purity is imrat when
the country was founded or Rea when the
first settlers came over and in the
Puritan culture you know the body was
considered almost ungodly because if you
were too concerned about your outward
appearance you weren't focused enough on
your spiritual life or at least that's
you know how their logic went well
sometime in the mid-1800s there came a
new movement called muscular
Christianity and this actually started
over in Europe but the idea was that you
know actually we have it backwards God
gave you this body and if you're really
trying to worship God to the utmost
you're gonna do as much and take care of
your body as much as you possibly can
and so this idea of muscular
Christianity really led to people well
led to males at least focusing more on
different aspects of sport in different
aspects of improving their bodies as a
way of kind of showing their religious
spirit and so if you're really really
tracing the roots back that's that's
where it all kind of starts and that's
obviously a very very rough rough sketch
and I would never explain it like that
in an academic talk but I think that if
you're trying to get the broad Overby
that's really more or less how it how it
started and then from there you know you
can get a lot into how technology and
media influence its growth and if I were
to pick two you know umbrella areas
those would be the ones that really
brought physical culture into the
mainstream so do you see that as like
the foundation of modern physical
culture in a way that's like
discontinuous with say ancient Greece
like do you think that there was
of a split such that it would be
improper to trace the roots you know all
the way back into the BC era
yeah it's it's it's contentious right I
mean there are obviously a lot of
traditions that began with the ancient
Greeks and Romans that you know still
our practice today and then there's a
lot that's not I mean the Olympics is
the obvious example right but then you
had art divided between the ancient
Olympics and the modern Olympics which
began in 1896 and/or 1892 actually think
and so it's it's it's difficult again
academics really love to argue these
nuances and I am just they don't
interest me so I might not be the best
person to ask from that perspective but
yeah I I personally would would look at
it more as an outgrowth at that muscular
Christianity movement and then changes
in technology and technology in the
media around the turn of the century for
me there those are kind of more relevant
factors well I mean you're the only
person with any academic qualifications
in the history of physical culture on
this podcast right now so regardless of
what the other people say in the context
of this podcast anything you say on the
subject I'm perfectly fine just taking
your word for it that's one of the nice
things about studying a really niche
topic is that you know unless you're
going to a conference about that topic
you're probably the only one who has any
idea of what you're talking about
[Laughter]
yeah I mean that that makes sense I I
should have thought of that yeah so
quick follow-up question for me Ben you
had mentioned that the muscular
Christianity movement was pretty much
exclusively male what was the when did
the tide turn and when did women kind of
enter the fray in terms of physical
culture in the West well you can
certainly find examples of females who
trained under what would be called
physical cultural practices in as early
as
early as the late 19th century but I
think you know you look at modern women
sport and it's far far different than
when the sport was at that time and I'm
honestly not an expert in that area and
so I'm really hesitant to make that make
any claims along that but the number of
you got to remember that even even when
this muscular Christianity movement was
on the people who trained exclusively
for the definition of physical culture
that I gave earlier it was it was pretty
niche and women were even more rare in
that arena you know you look at early
chips you look at gems dating all the
way back to the mid 20th century and
often times when there weren't even
allowed in them and so you know there's
obviously a lot of issues regarding
gender inequality that go into that and
and other societal factors that take it
much much more broad than physical
culture itself alright so just kind of
looping back to the second part of my
question so that's the roots of physical
culture in the West
what other physical culture traditions
are there out there or have there been
out there that you know our listeners in
the US Canada Europe might not be aware
of uh there's a lot there's a whole lot
I think the most important one to call
out would kind of be the Jenner Turner
movement the German Turner movement he's
I was also very influential in the
growth of his culture in the West and
that was essentially if I were to draw a
poor analogy it would be something like
you know talk p90x or other popular
exercise program that was focused mainly
on gymnastics calisthenics that sort of
resisted actually that sort of exercise
that wasn't strictly using resistance
although they did occasionally use like
dumbbells and things like that but that
was a big practice that was brought over
to the United States and largely
remained in German immigrant communities
and became integrated into larger
physical cultural practices and that was
pretty important in the evolution
of physical culture itself in America
other practices I think are cool you
know you can and actually Jan and and
rogue have done some some really cool
videos on these but you can look at the
stone lifting that was done in some of
the Icelandic countries and some some
areas of Spain you can look at the
wrestling that was done in India and
other areas in the East and oh boy
there's there's actually there's a whole
whole lot of different things that you
can go into you know the history of yoga
is very fascinating all those sorts of
things to me are really really cool but
it gets so broad because physical
culture itself is such a broad topic
that you could spend years studying any
one of these and then you did spend
years studying one particular topic or
at least you you obviously anyone doing
a PhD selects a topic for a dissertation
project and you did yours on Jack
LaLanne right yeah chuckling so why him
so originally well yeah originally my
focus was specifically on physical
culture and entrepreneurship in the 20th
century and 20th century in America so I
was looking at guys who practice
physical culture on their own and really
turned that into a business for
themselves or for their clients or for
other people or for whatever and
originally my plan for the dissertation
was to do a study on the spread of
unique gymnasiums throughout the country
because if you look at that spread it's
really really really really interesting
it begins on the East Coast obviously
because that's where you know most of
the early settlers were in the history
of the country but then moves over to
the west coast to California and then
spreads following post-world War two
where many of the soldiers who were
stationed in the West then went back to
their homes and were able to tell other
people about the gyms they interned at
California so the geographic spread is
really really interesting but right when
I was about to begin my dissertation
Jan was approached by Jacqueline's Widow
Elaine LaLanne who wanted to make a
donation of some information objects
letters and research and that sort of
thing to the Start Center and there was
a whole whole whole lot of information
we're talking boxes and boxes boxes of
letters of newspaper clippings of
different promotional and
business-related materials so just a
wealth of information that was all going
to be available to start Center and Jack
in particular was an extraordinarily
influential figure in both the history
of fitness in America and also in the
history of you know Fitness
entrepreneurship and Fitness celebrity
and so it was really a very natural
topic it was a pretty impactful topic
that would reach a broader audience than
my my planned study and so that's why I
decided to go with it it was really
lucky yeah I'm I'm glad you brought up
Fitness celebrity because I feel like a
lot of people today have never even
heard of Jack LaLanne actually first I
just like to comment that Elaine LaLanne
is like Bob Loblaw levels of the
legendary naming but yeah so my
grandmother was a huge Jack LaLanne fan
like had pictures of him clipped out
from magazines talked about the glory
days when he had as I understand it a
nationally syndicated TV show so like
how did he get that famous and like like
obviously there's big jacked people who
have also gotten famous and are still
famous for example Arnold Schwarzenegger
but as I understand it Jack LaLanne had
a TV program where he told people about
working out and like did workouts and a
bunch of people tuned in so like how did
that happen and why do you think that
hasn't been replicated because to a very
large extent he was lucky he was in the
right place at the right time God if it
was in California when the TV industry
began so if you look at the history of
television specifically it started out
well
you know the television was invented
much earlier but really people the
growth of television access exploded
after World War two exploded just
astronomical rates and so all of a
sudden there was this need for
programming right because you had gone
from almost nobody has TV to virtually
everyone has a TV in the span of a
decade and so you need programming to
fill all that time and so they were
looking for different types of shows and
Jack did have a certain charisma that he
could really project and make himself
very affable to to viewers even without
ever interacting with them one on one or
in person and that certainly helped him
out a lot but just the fact that Elaine
had a history of radio broadcasting so
she was already hooked into that kind of
culture and the fact that he was in
California where you know Los Angeles in
particular was the hotbed of television
programming at the time and so he had
the he had this specific knowledge right
because again physical culture is still
a niche thing it's growing very quickly
because all the soldiers who have been
in World War two were telling you know
their friends and their family back home
about all these cool things they saw
when they were stationed in California
you know there's a reason we we look at
Muscle Beach in California and see that
is you know the the birthplace of
bodybuilding even though it's really not
and so he had knowledge about this topic
he had a very pleasant way of conveying
it to to viewers that people wanted to
watch and then he was in the right place
at the right time
and so you know putting all those three
together is very very difficult to plan
it's not something that you can you know
really say oh you know I'm gonna be the
first person to start a TV show about
fitness if there's already 100 different
ones of them and then on the same token
you know if they're none at all coming
up with that idea is not something that
a lot of people are gonna do so that
that was that confluence of factors
really helped him I got you so I
actually have at least one more question
on Jack LaLanne but I want to pull out
one of the things you just said because
I found it interesting you said that a
lot of people think Muscle Beach is kind
of the the home of bodybuilding where it
got started but that's not the case so
I was laboring under the assumption here
that that was in fact true
so we're actually is like the birthplace
of bodybuilding and how did it then like
migrate to Muscle Beach and why do
people think that Muscle Beach is where
it all got started so I think actually
this is one area where most does
agriculture academics would agree that
bodybuilding started with Eugene Sandow
okay what a performing strongman but
also had an incredible physique and you
would travel through different circuses
and give demonstrations of strength but
also show off his body and that really
inspired them
Badar McFadden II saw at the World's
Fair in Chicago started inspired Bernard
McFadden to write a magazine about
physical culture and actually develop a
publishing Empire from it and you know
sponsor actual bodybuilding competitions
although they were very different than
the bodybuilding competitions we see
today so that's really where it started
I think the reason that so many people
associate it with Muscle Beach is again
because of the media industry and not
television it's time but the movies and
so if you're gonna trace that back you
you know there's actually an author who
calls the 1940s the age of the chest
because that was the time when you first
saw men not fully clothed in the movies
and you know one something several the
actors were very popular at the time had
really well developed pecs and that was
seen as very attractive and then when
you have the all the bodybuilders that
come to Muscle Beach to train their you
know whether it's because the bore
whether it's because of other factors
those things compound the the situation
or the the growth rather and so then you
start seeing these bodybuilders starring
in movies like Steve Reeves and Hercules
and and that really captures the
mainstream attention wears against and
out and McFadden were even though they
were very very prolific they still
weren't I wouldn't at least consider the
mainstream I got you so if I can kind of
go down this rabbit hole a little bit
further before looping back to Jack
LaLanne another thing you just mentioned
is that the early bodybuilding
competitions were you know much
different than what we see now what were
they like
you know they would first of all the
level of leanness was nowhere near what
it is today the level of muscularity was
nowhere near where it was today there
was a greater focus I think on muscular
control imposing in fluidity and there
were also athletic components of it
there were often times where you would
have to perform certain lifts or that
sort of thing and then finally the
judging was not exactly uh not exactly
well even today the judging is almost
completely subjective but I would say it
was even more so than I got you
so kind of looping back to Jack LaLanne
one of the one of the things we get
asked about a lot is to like talk more
about how how Fitness evolves and how
lifting should change and just kind of
what people should expect with the aging
process if they try to stay strong and
active I'm not a hundred percent sure
about the demographics of our podcast
audience but I know that our website
audience you know skews older than the
average Fitness site so a lot of people
ask us about that and one of the things
I know about Jack is he maintained
incredible physical shape as he got
older and one of the things he was kind
of famous for was performing feats of
athletic prowess when he turned like 60
65 70 years old and I don't remember the
details of any of them do you know some
of those just right off the top of your
head to kind of maybe dazzle our our
middle-aged and older listeners I think
his most popular one was the Escape from
Alcatraz right where he's on Alcatraz
Island handcuffed and he swims back to
the mainland a handcuff the entire way
and you know it's it wasn't really an
escape such as he didn't break out of
the jail but to make that swim it is
treacherous water in and that the
currents are very very strong and on top
of that it's
he's thinking cold you know so to
perform that feat was was pretty darn
impressive let let alone your swimming
handcuffed and it's over a mile I
believe that the total length was
something like one point four miles when
you're accounted for the for the current
so that was pretty pretty ridiculous the
other one that was really popular was
telling boats again handcuffed and
swimming all right he chose swimming in
particular because he had hurt his knee
playing football in high school and so
he was unable to run and so swing was
something that was you know kind of an
endurance sport that could also show off
his strength when he was talking to both
or whatever and so and it was something
so outlandish that it really caught
mainstream media attention do you
remember just right off the top of your
head how old he was when he did each of
those things he actually did most of
them twice he did them both and it was
almost always to celebrate a birthday he
claimed it was sometimes he didn't after
was always on his birthday but he
started out in his 40s and before most
of the stunts and then repeated them in
the 60s to show that he had maintained
that level fitness that's so cool
I've got a follow-up question about Jack
because so Greg you mentioned that your
grandmother I think was a big fan and my
grandfather was as well and the question
I have is did he have went when he was
you know at his peak popularity with a
TV show and everything else did he have
rivals or peers that were anywhere on
like a similar tier or was he just kind
of a essentially a one-man fitness
industry he absolutely did
you know I'm one that I've written quite
extensively about his Debbie Drake who
was obviously a woman but her show was
extraordinary popular mainly because she
would perform the exercises and what was
then considered pretty provocative
clothing and so she would have two women
watching because the women wanted to
look like her and she was she would have
the men watching because the men wanted
to watch a woman dressed like that
contorting herself on the floor so she
was very very popular then later when
you get into the 1980
and remember Jax show was syndicated so
it's still being broadcast then you have
people like Jane Fonda so you can really
the he was by no means the only person
in this space there were a lot of other
people as well who were lesser who were
not as well-known and who also practiced
different forms of physical culture so
for example uh yoga was one that had
several TV shows about you know how to
perform yoga and introduce yoga to a
Western audience and there were some
some shows with military background
actually her roots in the military where
they would show calisthenics that were
performed by the military further for
general fitness in the 1950s national
fitness became kind of a bigger
mainstream concern not only because I
mean it media because but because of the
whole Cold War and there was the idea
that we had to be fit as a nation to
fight communism and so there were
several shows there's several
opportunities for other people to enter
that space what uh what current country
do you think we should start another
Cold War with to get people interested
in physical culture and getting jacked
again just out of curiosity if you had
to orchestrate a geopolitical conflict
who you got it would absolutely be
Russia again I want to see a battle of
the giant plates and see how thick we
can get our dead with plates how much we
can make that bar Bend because you know
you look at the she what is at the WRP
sea and how they used the thicker plates
and the in their championships and I
would love to see that over I think
that's a good call I mean we beat them
once we can do it again absolutely I
wouldn't discount the Netherlands though
I feel like they're a good outfit I
would like to jump in here and just say
that I will have the opportunity to go
to the Netherlands next year I'm gonna
meet my coach Mike Teixeira and I'm
gonna be giving a talk at the National
Museum for photography there about
powerlifting and bodybuilding how they
kind of relate to the media so I'm
pretty excited about that I was actually
going to ask you about that because I
saw that on your Instagram and I would
is just just going to kind of put it out
there to ask if maybe I could give you
an undefined substance to attempt to
slip in their water supply
surreptitiously but we can talk about
that once we're done recording
okay so is is there anything else that
you think is really really cool about
Jack LaLanne that most people don't know
that they should know um what the
coolest thing I always thought was how
he he trained for his swims or for his
mental strength you know I think a lot
of those feats and endurance that he did
were more mentally demanding than
physically demanding in some ways and so
the the extremes that he went to
practice for them like he would sit in a
bathtub and just have a lame pour ice
over him again and again again just sit
there for hours so that the kulluk
wouldn't bother him things like that to
me where were the most impressive by far
that makes sense so Ben you mentioned
some pretty incredible feats athletic
feats that Jack accomplished but
obviously you've got a very deep
understanding of the history of physical
culture do you have like a favorite
lifter or a favorite lifting achievement
that most people have never heard about
um you know I'm not really sure it's
hard for me to say because it's hard for
me to have perspective on what lifting
was like back in those times but if I
had to pick one I think Bob people's who
was the first person to pull 700 pound
deadlift at 181 I think that was a
really really cool story he was trained
by my advisors husband Terry Todd and he
actually had a very unique style of
deadlifting where he would deadlift with
a very very rounded back and was still
able to lock out enormous amounts of
weights and Terry also trained Lamar
Gant who had scoliosis bad scoliosis and
pulled the same way and Terry stow
claimed until his death that Omar game
was the most impressive lifter of all
time for the feats that he was able to
perform at such low low body weights so
those guys were definitely definitely be
up there is it controversial to suggest
that Lamar Gann
is the best powerlifter of all time I
think that it probably is and it
shouldn't be I think he gets overlooked
because he lifted in smaller weight
glasses you know people want to see the
biggest guys lifting the biggest way
possible and I think that's a shame
because I do think it's pretty cool how
smaller guys are able to lift enormous
weights but at the same time now that I
am trying to add almost mice I see that
it doesn't help you as much as you might
think like adding 30 pounds to your
lifts while adding 30 pounds to your
body weight won't necessarily make your
lifts go up 100 so I have appreciation
for both sides but yeah I do it I do
wish the smaller let's just got more
recognition so so just out of curiosity
why Lamar Gant
instead of someone like Hideki Inaba or
like in more modern times feta Cinco or
Olek oh I guess you didn't I thought I
were thinking you were thinking somebody
I studied specifically and I didn't I
you know I was pretty focused on
American lifters no fair enough
who do you personally think is super
impressive that maybe no one has heard
about because I assume most of our
lifters are going to look most of our
listeners are going to be at least
somewhat familiar with Lamar can't
so who's who's kind of like either a
super super old school physical
culturist
or like a more obscure lifter who's done
something that you find super impressive
that that more people should know about
yeah I mean I would still defer it about
people's their you know Sandow is
definitely somebody to study he's
actually many many people have studied
Sandow and the feats that he performed
were pretty cool but again back before
formal records were recorded you could
really make up what the amounts that
we're lifting and nobody would be able
to call be able to call you out on them
so I always take those older guys with a
grain of salt fair enough all right so
moving on to somewhat new territory I
guess we have touched on this a little
bit and it's a question we talked about
before we started recording and you said
very understandably that there's no way
you could get into all of it
but just in general how have opinions on
strength training changed over time and
how has media portrayal of strength
training and being big and muscular
changed over time because it it seems
like back in the day it used to be
something that was cool and then kind of
cardio and aerobics had a had a big day
in the Sun in the 80s and 90s and you
know now there's more superhero movies
more interest in resistance training
again it seems so like how have those
opinions shifted and what seemed to be
some of the factors driving those shifts
over time yeah so I think we've already
covered you know kind of the origins
physical culture and then how its spread
following World War two I think you can
really look at the media following World
War two and see a lot of really very
interesting ways that popular culture
have has influenced strength training
what my very favorite example is the
advent of superheroes and particularly
Superman and the Superman comics because
you look at Superman in the 1940s and
50s and he looks almost like a normal
guy and then you look at Superman today
and he looks like you know he would put
Kai Green to shame and that coincided
with the that that change in how
Superman was portrayed coincided with
the proliferation of anabolic steroids
so that I think is something that's very
very interesting to look at and also you
know when you look at the way that
health and fitness have been kind of
conflated with each other I think that
is almost entirely driven by the media
because you have images of and this this
you can trace back very very far but you
have images in magazines and TV shows of
whether it's a professional bodybuilder
whether it's a fitness model whatever
the case may be of hey this person looks
beautiful therefore they are healthy and
when in reality you know what that
person did to look that way was probably
very unhealthy and I would contribute
that almost entirely to the media when
you look at strength training in
particular I think again the superhero
thing was pretty big I think that Arnold
and the guys that I mentioned the movies
were very very big in that and so I
could go on for a very very long time I
think he specifically mentioned the
cardio boom that though was more driven
by fears of health actual concerns over
health um when president I should really
know this off the top of my head I want
to say President Eisenhower had a heart
attack on a golf course that really
raised fears of this silent killer that
men in the United States were unfit
because they had too much stress in
their lives they didn't have enough
physical activity and that really
coincided with some of the space
programs some of the other things that
people needed to be fit for and so all
of that kind of gave rise to two
aerobics to running and to that that
area of physical culture and so again I
could it's an extraordinarily difficult
question because again you could spend a
lifetime studying this stuff and so
hopefully those few examples are kind of
interesting for people we want to look
them up on their own but to dive in deep
even any one of them you could write a
whole dissertation one that makes sense
I think that kind of comes to an end of
the pre-prepared questions we had did
you have anything left Asterix no I will
say when when you said a fear of health
about that cardio boom I thought you
said a fear of hell and I thought this
was gonna circle all the way back around
a muscular Christianity I was on the
edge of my seat man I like that that
could be in my alternative history my
alternative dissertation we are all
sinners in the hands of an angry god but
if you can maintain a six-minute mile
pace you can escape that hand I'm going
to hell no that was the way my ear heard
it I was like I can't wait to see where
this goes
I'm sorry I feel like we could write
physical culture fanfic about it I think
that's already been done right I don't
know I II will
to be to being fully out of the loop
when it comes to lifting related fanfic
I'm sure there's a community for it so
then we want to stay respectful of your
time you've been here for for over an
hour at this point is there anything you
would like to leave the listeners with
just in terms of closing thoughts you
know I I don't know that I want to leave
the listeners with this but I do want to
thank you guys for the information you
put out I think one of the things that
really gets to me in the fitness
industry is how much terrible
information there is and so what you
guys are doing with the website with the
podcast with mass I really really
appreciate it I think that you are
making the industry better for everyone
you know regardless of how that
knowledge is use the fact that you're
putting out good stuff is very very
important to me so I wanted to thank you
all for that
well that that honestly means a lot
you're you're one of a relatively small
handful of people in the industry who I
feel incredibly confident pointing
people towards knowing that you will
also pervade good information their way
so that that honestly does mean a whole
lot coming from you and Ben he doesn't
say that to every guest no like two
prior guests have have tried to feed me
that line and it's just like cool thanks
[Laughter]
just kidding
maybe so alright just kind of in closing
where can people find you
how can people connect with you and your
media empire probably the best easiest
way is just Instagram my my name is pH
deadlift from there that's probably the
easiest way to find me but I tried to
use that pretty consistently so that
it's easy fine you can check out my
website at pH deadlift calm and if you
have questions you can email me at been
at pH deadlift or calm so it's all
pretty pretty straightforward and you
know I'm happy to do my best to help
like I said most of this stuff is
individual so you know broad questions
are kind of difficult to answer but I'll
do my best
sweet well thank you so much for coming
on thanks for having me guys I really
appreciate it thanks for listening to
the stronger by science pocket
now Greg and I are not experts in
medicine or health or really anything
else for that matter so before you make
any changes to your diet and exercise
habits make sure you check with a doctor
or another healthcare professional if
you enjoyed this podcast and you'd like
to support it
visit stronger by science com to check
out the products and services that we
offer thanks for listening and we'll see
you next time
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]